what up guys welcome to the just pearly
things YouTube channel and welcome to
the pregame
start do not forget to subscribe to the
channel and ring that notification Bell
the way you're going to be notified of
my daily videos like the video on your
way in as that is the most important
metric that YouTube uses to push out
these videos also guys you already know
the drill if you have watched two or
more of my lives and you do not
subscribe we have beef okay beef people
so today I have a lovely panel um why
don't we go around everyone say your
name your age your relationship status
and a fun fact about yourself starting
here going around and then the second
row
uh my name is rashan I'm 24.
single
fun facts
I like pineapple and pizza
my name is Elena I'm 21
I'm single and I like to do puzzles
my name is Natalie I'm 27.
um
I'm single and very happy
do we have to talk about what we do if
you want if that's your fun fact I'm
zoned out I don't know oh it's your name
your age your relationship status and a
fun fact so it could just be you know
I'm an artist so like I produce my own
music I release it myself I write I sing
yeah
oh I'm Priscilla I'm 34. I'm married and
a fun fact I have six kids
six kids wow that's amazing I didn't
push them all out
I am Seward I'm 35 and
um single
fun fact
there is no fun fact that's the fun fact
um I'm Lola I'm 24 I'm single and fun
fact about me when I have free time I do
Tick Tock videos
you want to plug your Tick Tock what is
it tell the people I mean it's Lola
underscore Amanda
hi I'm Auntie Jenny 55.
in a relationship
fun fact
I'm here hey
will you will you stay here this show
I'll do my best
okay
um so today's topic is
can can modern relationships work so uh
my question is for do you for the single
people have you ever been in a
traditional relationship or and people
in a relationship sorry for the people
in a relationship are you in a
traditional relationship and for the
single people have you ever been in a
traditional relationship and how did you
like it well sorry what do you mean by
traditional
um just like what you think of when you
think of like like the man pays for
everything he he leads you follow like
that sort of thing
okay do you want me to answer that
um yes yeah why don't we start here and
then go around yeah sorry
um
I I guess yes in some aspects like he
would lead and I would follow
um he paid
yeah he paid for everything on this like
I offered and said oh I've got it this
time
um that's I guess that's as traditional
because we didn't live together and
honestly we weren't married so okay okay
what about you
I don't think I have been in a
traditional relationship as such that it
was all very 50 50. he didn't really
lead much so yeah I don't think I have
no okay
no never been a traditional relationship
no
um yes so I'm married and
um I hesitate because we have a blended
family so it's not traditional in a
sense of like nuclear we got together
and had babies
um but we had children before we got
together and got married and now we're a
blended family but um in a sense of
black roles
um yes I am I am a traditional wife
and yeah I follow his lead and yeah
essentially he leads the family
um I've been married before so I'm
divorced but I wasn't in a traditional
marriage or relationship
what made it not traditional
um I guess I was in my
masculine energy and
uh
I was
doing everything essentially and he was
um not really
the man that I I want
um that I now want you know after some
searching and understanding what my role
is as a woman what I would ideally like
from a man and what they want from women
more importantly
um so yeah that's what when you say in
your masculine what do you mean by that
um so I made the decisions for the
family oh okay
um financially
and more
um just everything really I just kind of
felt like
uh I mean I don't want to be too
disrespectful here because you know he's
the father of my kid and
um there's certain boundaries that you
don't talk about on there but
I I was in my masculine energy okay okay
go ahead
um
I think to an extent my relationship was
quite traditional but I think when it
comes to like personality and stuff I
think I was more of the domineering
character compared to him so I would say
in that sense I kind of witnessed that I
was more of the leader than he was and I
think that's probably why like things
didn't really work out between us but
yeah
hmm
auntie I don't think um
relationship for me now they hear it
perfect previous relationship I've tried
to make them lead and they have been
able to so I just had to go
you just forcing them to leave because
some men just don't want to lead someone
just don't know how to lead or they
can't yeah the one I've got now he can
he does
so for the girls that's sad because I
think you two said you've never been in
a traditional relationship do you guys
enjoy did you enjoy being in a more
modern relationship
do you want to answer that first
definitely not no I'm very I'm quite old
school even I'm young like I've got
quite old soul and I've always wanted
you know just to be one man for my whole
life and
it just wasn't that he wasn't giving me
that he wasn't really at the beginning
he was putting in a lot of effort but
towards the end it wasn't really there
and that's why it probably ended
what was what was the question again
what was it like being in a modern
relationship did you enjoy it um
and is that something you'd want in the
future sorry I think of these questions
elements of it I enjoyed
however
I don't know I feel like um so my
biggest fear my biggest fear is
financially depending on somebody
but it's my it terrifies me I never ever
ever want to Corona home with someone
I never win a CO in a business with
someone I never want to be financially
tied to a man because I've seen so many
women in my life be absolutely dictated
financially by men there's no hate or
men men are wonderful I know some
amazing men but no one's ever made me
feel safe enough to embrace my feminine
side with a man
which is why
I've always had my own businesses I have
my own car
getting emotional yeah I can hear it
yeah
I went through something really wild
recently
my ex committed identity theft fraud
against me with his mum
that's what my EP is about
I'm not even using that as an excuse to
plug myself I'm just being transparent
because it justifies
I didn't trust anyone to take care of me
I got this
and until I meet someone that makes me
feel safe enough emotionally spiritually
and physically
then I will consider being in a
traditional relationship
I'm good I'm not even crying thank you
thank you though thanks um
do you think that's going to be hard for
for the next guy yeah because it's like
he kind of has to deal with the mistakes
of like your past in a way yeah you know
what it already has
been hard for the next guy and the guy
after that and the guy after that not
that not that I'm you know moving about
in different ways but you know
I go out a lot I have a very social job
like I perform for a living I sing so I
meet a lot of people and I've met some
wonderful people but there's something
within me that's just like but can I
trust you have I known you long enough
because the guy that was with last time
was one of my best friends
and I knew him for a couple of years
before I was with him and then to do
that and other things which I can't
discuss I'm like well who can I trust
so I can ask a question
do you at what point do you think you
need to do some healing I you know the
sound and I don't mean that
disrespectfully I hope you no
I don't take it disrespectfully the bat
the sad thing is I've already done so
much healing
with all due respect it doesn't sound
like it though I know I know what he
didn't have you done do you know I ran
to the other side of the world I just
got back from Australia I spent six
weeks traveling around Australia and
this is because when I broke up with him
after I found out about the fraud are
the women from his past were coming
forward to me
messaging me and these little women he
smear campaigns saying that one's uh
used to beat me up she was a drug addict
she was an alcoholic so I blocked them
all thinking it was true and out of
curiosity I unblocked them because I
knew they were trying to reach out to me
and one by one they slowly came forward
to me with their screenshots and their
truths and their lovely educated women
and it frightened me because I was
sharing a bed with this person you know
I was living with him I was running a
business from his home
and all of a sudden I'm discovering all
of these things I I had no idea he was
capable of and they're such nice women
they're my friends now they help me
you're friends with his ex I'm friends
with them yeah
couple of them but like how do you heal
if you're friends with his past I would
say that because they justify I
understand and I think you're right
however they Justified everything I went
through was real because you go through
this thing called cognitive dissonance
when you're trying to break a trauma
bomb with someone and it's where you try
and justify their behavior but they were
really nice they were so good to me they
validated my feelings but simultaneously
they're emotionally abusing You by doing
other things isolating you like I think
that's what we do as women though we
come together and then we talk about you
know he done this she done that yeah of
course and then there's no actual
healing that's being done yeah so like
whether it's spiritually whether it's
mentally you know talking to a therapist
talking to someone that you trust
getting it out
and then it won't be so hard on the next
guy that comes along and it won't be
hard on you as has this been a pattern
or has it just been him I mean obviously
that's pretty far but has it been a
pattern of like toxic guys in a way I've
had some lovely guys and then some not
so I the others I think they were just
young I don't think they're bad people I
don't even think this last one is a bad
person I just think he's not
and it made you move to Australia for
six weeks and to use you I'm gonna be
friends with you sex sorry
okay I just I don't know if he's bad or
he's just done well you know I know he
had borderline personality disorder I
know when I got with him he was severely
anorexic he had a lot of demons that I
tried to help him with and equally I'm
not gonna lie he helped me with my so
that's why I don't know if he's bad or
if he was just so he couldn't stand the
thought did you know there was demons
like early on when we were friends no no
but when you started dating him you kind
of saw a couple red flags early on oh
yeah when it started interfering with my
work so I'm assuming that like you had
have guy friends yeah I'm sure would
date you right
so what made you go with like the toxic
guy over the nice guy it was very
exciting what it was exciting do you
know what I would be so honest about
this I appreciate the honesty and um I
think this is when my growth period
happened I before him I always wanted to
be that girl that could be taken care of
be driven around in a nice car taken out
to nice meals bought nice bags nice
jewelry because I never you know I never
had a guy that did that until my ex he
bought me he did all of that for me and
until I found myself sitting in that
Benz with the heated seats I was like
I'm really unhappy because this man does
not love himself enough to be with me he
doesn't know who he is he's unhappy he
takes it out on me because he's not
secure within himself
and now I drive around at my little
Toyota Yaris and I'm just like you know
what this is all I need I'm happy now
I'm good
um
I can't remember your question no sorry
so so you almost put up with more
because he was rich
I think it was more
I think at the beginning that enticed me
but it wasn't that I actually loved him
100 I love you you didn't love her I did
love him
you just said it was because of like the
cars and it enticed me yeah it enticed
me but he didn't he didn't maintain me I
financed myself he tried to buy me a car
I said no try to invest in my business I
said no he tried to buy me a phone I
said no because I even back then I was
aware that if we break up you're gonna
turn around and say give me that back
now I don't want to ever be in that
position
so no you know it entitles me that he
could take care of himself he had all
these things it inspired me I'm not a
gold digger otherwise I would have
accepted all those things he offered me
it was more I was inspired by his
lifestyle I wanted that for myself
that's inspired by his life what does
that mean well he could drive that car
he owned that car he's younger than me
I'm like wow I want that okay so it just
it just I'm just confused because it
kind of it kind of is like you're saying
the same thing okay
okay you just wanted like the hey hey
life really yeah
it's cool okay
um
so
what about you guys have you guys ever
dated a toxic guy anyone raise your hand
raise your hand you're a razor no kind
of yeah I mean the thing is though when
I look back on it I'm like was it really
toxic or did I just not know myself was
I just not secure in myself
um and I think also the word toxic is
thrown around so much and you know
sometimes when you're talking with your
friends and they're just like oh that's
so toxic but looking back I'm thinking
we were both young he was just doing him
and I was just so like you know I I no I
won't say it was toxic maybe on my
behalf I had an unhealthy attachment but
I I looking back on it I wouldn't say he
was toxic okay so you don't think he was
toxic
okay and what about you Mum was a
hundred thousand percent toxic I just
came to the realization as I was saying
now now though he wasn't toxic
I was just like toxic not I don't know
um yeah a million percent I think
maybe I was the opposite in my head I
was trying to make it seem like he
wasn't
um and I would always defend him I'd be
out here defend him to everyone my
parents like my whole family my friends
even to him like his family his friends
I'm like no this is the guy for me even
to myself like I become so deluded
because I was so in love but I feel like
again this love bombing phase in the
beginning like maybe I grew attached and
fell in love with someone that doesn't
actually exist
um
but yeah it was just the the regular
things of just being unfaithful maybe he
just couldn't commit and he wasn't the
guy for me but for someone else it may
not be damn toxic but for me when I'm
with someone I'm very tunnel vision so
if they're not the same like what type
of toxic things did he do
there was a few there was just loads of
messages he would just go hot and cold
like days weeks no communication I was
with him so you were dating him he
didn't talk to you for weeks yep he
would just disappear and be like oh I
just don't want to talk or he sent a
little messages like I just don't want
to talk and I'd be like okay when when
people go through things I'm someone I
give you space I'm not needy I don't
need to be talking to you 24 7 you have
your space but then it become a regular
thing and I was like either there's
something wrong with you or there's
something up here
um and I'm a big Communicator so if you
can't talk to me about stuff if I am
whatever but I will try and try and try
it but you know in the end I won't bug
you
um I found condom wrappers and I was
doing the laundry you know being they've
been that good housewife and yeah no it
was just a lot and I'd say it's quite
damaging but at the same time you learn
from it you learn what you don't want
and how old were you guys when you dated
the toxic guy
recently so in 19 20 21. oh so you're
you're 21 when you dated him okay that
was only like eight months ago okay and
then how many how many years were you
guys with him
together solidly about a year and a bit
and then on and off I'd say two and a
half years two and a half years a year
and a bit a year and a bit but we were
friends for we're like really close
friends for two years before that so
okay and I'm curious did you guys ever
you said you caught him cheating
yes yeah you're not in the ACT but yeah
yeah I'm cheating
I don't think he ever cheated on me but
then I don't know at the same time
anymore there's so much that I just
didn't know
I don't want to get into that okay no no
worries um when you caught him cheating
did you stay or did you leave I left
okay but went back shortly after
I left the house and then went back and
forth and back and forth but yeah it's
not a good cycle to being 100 okay
would any of you guys be open to dating
a guy
um that it's closed on your end but open
on his where he would sleep with other
girls no no no no no not that I know
about it but you might
you might hail too it depends it depends
yeah okay what about you no no
um so I'm going to tweak it a little bit
okay
um so for me
um it's dating to marriage and it's not
really dating as in a sense of how
you guys would see it it would be we
want to get married he'd be talking to
my mom and my dad my brothers getting to
know me with my the male family members
involved
um so I wouldn't uh sorry I forgot the
question
um
I was just asking if you would ever be
open to dating a guy where he's able to
cheat but you're not basically um so we
would be married and if he wanted
another wife where I am now
um with the mindset that I have now
um I wouldn't mind if you had another
wife but this is not another wife this
is being unfaithful but but I I'm not I
don't date men yeah so do you see what
I'm saying that's why I said the
tweaking I don't like I don't have a
boyfriend and I won't have a boyfriend
because I'm a Muslim woman we don't oh
you know that's yeah that's strictly
forbidden
um so would you be okay with your
husband sleeping around with loads of
different women then I guess that's the
Tweet not necessarily having one wife it
would be sleeping with those of other
women
but no she said that what she'd be happy
with her husband having another wife
yeah yeah not a side piece yeah yeah so
but you'd be okay with 2y who would be
okay with a second wife anyone anyway no
no no do you know what yeah she does
everything it's at the bedroom I'll be
happy
um so you said no hell no and what about
if it was just like casual stuff and
then you're the main girl no why why are
you ranking who's casual in here yeah
yeah either one or none simple I thought
I'd become normalized too normalized
like people who believe in polygamy need
to stay with them people they can't try
and convert the people who want monogamy
in life but they do and that's where
this toxic stuff happens yeah yeah
agree that all right auntie
oh can you tell the story about when you
caught the guy cheating anyone in the
bedroom yeah oh exactly oh yeah
um I've seen this guy for a long while
and he's supposed to take me shopping he
didn't turn up so I went to his house
but we used to hang out with all of his
friends that was one of the guys and
then this lovely young lady
I said hi
and I asked where he was and she knew me
because she's always upstairs now we're
not upstairs
and he just sort of like she climbs into
bed and he was just
and I was like and you can see him
trying to oh you're already in bed of
her yeah I've seen trying to distance
himself and I said to her
is that your man
she says yeah I said hug him up we don't
matter whoever's there you hug him up
and she's like I said hug him harder
he's gonna be like a cup of coffee
I said yes please and she wouldn't
answer it and he said that's what you
want me to say
what do you want me to do because I'm
not going to hit her do you want me to
knock you out I said I don't want to
scream and shout
I'm just gonna sit here
I think I had lunch as well yeah I ended
up being her friend because I would hang
out with all the guys and all the guys
was like no when did you tell her did
you tell her she must be known that
she's watching this
I didn't tell her I was a friend he's a
player I played at my Mom's party yes I
said you come in she said no he didn't
invite me I said you come
how long does this go on for
until they split up until oh stop yeah
you stopped anything with him oh no
straight away yeah I stopped but it was
just fun to go there I used to go there
when he wasn't there she goes oh he's
coming home soon you know I'm just
popping out to the shop so I watch
dinner and I thought this is what you're
having for dinner yeah tormented yeah
but I was nice about it and I did
disrespect her you know and then one day
he turned up and his whole car was
covered in white paint I was just like
oh dear what did you do
[Music]
but yeah he deserved what she gave him
clearly why would she painted it put all
the paint all over his car glass as well
yeah you know what I don't have that in
me I know some people have like ripped
windscreen wipers off they've keyed cars
they've done all of that I just I feel
like I don't have it in me I could be so
angry and upset but I just you do it in
your head yeah just do that do you think
if we flipped the genders that it would
be the same reaction like if I if I if I
said oh I cheated on a guy and he put
pain all over my card and keyed it like
people would have the same reaction of
course that's Petty I don't think they
expect the whole car to disappear
a man wouldn't do something like that
you just come out the car be gone no but
it's if they want it to be pretty it's
just interesting because I I feel like
if it was the opposite like if I said oh
he keyed my car and did this after I
cheated like it wouldn't result in
people laughing you know what I mean
yeah
I think they think he's pathetic a lot
of people would say that he's dangerous
yeah yeah he's violent or he's unhinged
or abusive yeah I think so yeah 100
women
soft I'll be like I'm glad it was the
current not me yeah but I just think the
way people are nowadays men are the
villains in every scenario and anything
that happens to a woman if you flip it
on its head and it happening to a man
it's always worse because women are
Saints we cannot do anything wrong do
you think so perfect no I do not like
she said that tongue-in-cheek because
you see her smile I do not think so but
I feel like Society
I just think conversation to make it
seem like that is the consensus but even
like when we talk about cheating like if
the guy does it it's always we demonize
him but if the girl does it the first
question is always why like why what
made her cheat why did she cheat I no I
would I would say I would always ask why
did the guy cheat I always I don't think
that's do you think you think that's
common when you see it on when you see
it on say tick tock when they tell
cheating stories it's always that if you
look at any cheating story on Tick Tock
if it's a girl telling it the story of
how she cheated like they'll always say
oh well why did she cheat
what yeah but for the men it's like you
know if I say he cheated because he
hasn't slept his wife hasn't slept with
him in three years they still may come
out to be the bad guy yeah okay yeah
fair enough actually I don't think
you're wrong it's like you know one out
of four marriages is a sexless usually
on the man's part or like on the woman's
part yeah oh wow yeah one out of four
I've known I've known somebody and been
married yes
yeah yeah I don't think I could it's
easy to slip into could you when you
have babies yeah then you look at you no
I'm sorry it's easy to slip into I
honestly I just feel like when we have
conversations about sex in marriage like
women have to be honest there are points
in your marriage where you have to make
an effort where you have to look at your
husband and say okay he needs to take
one for the team
capacity and I may not feel like it for
the foreseeable so let me Avail myself
in the same way you would want like your
husband or your partner to eval himself
in whatever of our scenario or even the
same I just feel like it is not that
uncommon for a woman to not want to have
sex because when you become when you are
a woman of a house you've got a lot
going on especially if you work as well
there's a lot happening and you have
babies and stuff like that I just feel
like sometimes yes
like the wife is required to make an
effort she's not always going to feel
like it but some women choose not to
make an effort some women are like I
will wait until I feel like it and you
will wait until I feel like it can I ask
you a question so if you didn't feel
lucky you still do it
well if he wanted to I just feel like my
husband but
yes yeah like I will I will because he
needs he needs me in that room like I
just feel like for men it's not always
I'm horny like it's
like their way of connecting to you
they're like they want to be close to
you and they don't want to sit down and
have a gossip about what they did they
don't want to listen to your like
stories that you say is going to be two
minutes but actually it's an hour and a
half they want to connect like that way
like just sometimes you have to Avail
yourself yeah
sure you watch me and one of pearls
podcast before Pearl no you remember the
one we asked about the women what's your
opinion Auntie what if what if she
doesn't feel like it that's like she
don't feel like it you know just like
read a book bend over and just like you
know watch TV be on the phone
not not always because the fact of the
matter is is if you are with someone
that person loves you and understands
you so if you don't feel like it there's
going to be times this one yeah yeah
leave it alone but then sometimes like
you may not feel like it for like two
months wow
you might have had a baby you might have
been traumatic whatever
you know so if you having a baby not
talking about you but just like you know
yeah if he was having a baby you didn't
feel like it is there other ways that
you can please your man okay then just
checking okay we all yeah we all know
there's a real grown unaware no because
I said this before and I and I said that
you know basically a woman should refuse
a man you know if it her husbands yeah
that you know I mean yeah exactly but
for women they want to make love for a
man it's just like give me five minutes
can I ask you I think that's okay what
happens if you're really angry at him
about something he's done and he wants
it right there and then like do you do
it
myself
that could be better than counseling
yeah
you're being so angry that I don't want
to have sex I've never had makeup
they're saying that's the best kind
sorry Mom I'm just saying I've never had
makeup so you've never on either vampire
we're gonna talk it out oh yeah and I
thought you might touch me no I didn't
say makeup text I I always think of like
you've sorted out and yeah yeah
it's not to solve it and I feel like
people come closer and it's nice yeah
but that's where that's why you get
stuck in your toxic situation I'm not
having a go because I've done the same
yeah if you're happy I wouldn't do it to
mask I think mask is the perfect word
yeah you can't have sex if you're not
happy you can't make love yeah you have
to so you've got to make sure that the
problems solve you can't just say oh
yeah you know everything's fine but deep
inside you're angry yeah you have to
clear it because yeah you know you can't
have Angry sex but I don't think you can
have sex if you're not fully in it
anyway well that's me personally I don't
know about you I'll do it just to let
him shut up I'll give him five minutes
I also don't think foreplay Works yes
yeah the general rule is if you want to
eat you like you have to prepare it like
yeah cook it
marinated
how long how long do you think a guy if
he goes without like okay I'm trying to
phrase this question so how long let's
say you haven't had sex with him in a
month is it acceptable for him to cheat
no like like at what point
um have you like not slept with your guy
where it's kind of understandable that
he steps out because we could agree
probably that if you haven't slept with
him in two years he's probably gonna
step out and some men don't sleep with
him in a month I think he's over I think
it's happening he's finished with me
I've got a question actually off the
back of that no it's not you it's like
you not sleeping yeah and all seriously
never like a guy has been deprived for
that long like get to the point of
saying you've deprived me for this long
I feel like I need it and I'm gonna get
it like just talk to me yeah
communication yeah if he's addressed it
to me and come come to me and be like
look this is how I'm feeling retiter and
I haven't tried I think the same as an
argument and I haven't tried to resolve
it yeah resolve it at that point leave
me but that's I feel like that's simple
for a lot of guys because it acts like
they lose custody to their kids no I
think I know I agree it's not that
simple but if you want me to answer the
question
no but in real life everything's a
little bit more complex than that so I
get it there's exceptions of everything
I think that well yeah and I honestly I
just feel like even like me as a male
person like I've told my husband this
before I don't feel like cheating is a
deal breaker if
I just don't feel like changes I feel
like you can literally work through
anything I really do but oh like just to
answer your question right no no no yeah
but at least like two months okay two
months is two months for that okay no at
least like some people will be like oh
we're having sex in two weeks
what aspect are we okay so why wouldn't
you be having sex with him sometimes
whatever the reason yeah some girls yeah
we can yeah like some girls do it to
like control the guy
yeah sadistic I think sometimes I
remember one in four marriages are
sexless I mean maybe she married she
didn't marry the guy she wanted and
she's not really attracted to him
anymore yeah I mean there's a million
reasons I think if it started that way
then it's different if it's changed like
throughout you need to look at what's
changed it but sometimes it's also like
where you are at mentally yeah yeah and
if you're someone who like suffers from
depression that can affect how you feel
sexually yeah and unfortunately sorted
and unfortunately unfortunately
unfortunately
like it's not personal to your partner
but obviously it does affect your
partner but you should be able to
communicate clearly why you're feeling
like you're feeling so that he doesn't
feel iced out because men will actually
if you if you go to if you go to touch
you and you're like he's gonna feel iced
out so and then hopefully you have a
compassionate apartment I just don't
know what you could tell I'm like baby
we're not gonna have sex for three
months but this is how I'm feeling yeah
yes can you understand well mine did I
think foundationally what helps is if
both both people in the relationship can
agree that if we haven't had sex in a
while there's actually a problem because
one might not see it like the woman that
is withholding sex Humanity has a
problem but if we can agree that I I
don't feel I have not felt like having
sex with you for like over a week or two
weeks she within herself should be able
to say I may not know why but this is
definitely a problem yeah but but you
you always know why you just need to dig
deep like I knew why I I at first I was
like oh I'm not too sure and then I did
and I've told him I was like this is why
and he was
we have an open not open relationship in
terms of other people but in terms of
like openly communicating I don't feel
like no one should be having sex if you
can't talk about sex you certainly
shouldn't be having been in a
relationship you can't talk about sex
with your partner and why you don't have
sex or what you like what you don't like
etc etc and hopefully the person that
you have respect you as a human being
and says okay I can see why you're going
through that like do you know how long I
know if you can honestly say look I
don't know how I'm gonna feel if that
person then turns around and says well I
thought like at least wait a certain
time period before you go
okay it's been a while is anything
changing no yeah one woman should get
proactive about it
what is the longest has any of us been
without sex in a relationship and who
stopped it what's the longest you've
been in your relationship without sex so
I can't answer that
okay can I yes
I just jumped in I don't know if anyone
else okay
I don't
so one of my exes was anorexic
he had an eating disorder
and I used to hate sleeping with him
because I could feel his hip bones and
it used to make me feel
uncomfortable it would hurt
and it put me off and
trying to help someone overcome that and
support them but also trying to be
intimate with them when you're not
feeling it because it physically hurts
is a hard thing to stay in
so um that was not a very
sexy relationship so how long was it
that was a year and a bit no I mean how
long without that sex no no no no no no
because he started he started getting I
couldn't do it to myself
wait did you cheat on him no I've never
I've never I couldn't
if I'm either in or I'm out I don't run
around in Gray areas I don't it's just
not how I roll so for me
that we weren't intimate for about a
good
it was like on and off because some I'm
trying to think probably about a good
four or five months but just you didn't
have sex with him for four or five
months yeah and it's because you didn't
want to did he know the reason why I had
no I had to be honest in the end do you
think if the roles were reversed yeah
you would have like taken that okay and
you know what it's interesting you're
saying that I called myself out on it
today because my friend said to me that
a guy she was with
made a comment about her weight in the
bedroom and it made me reflect and think
God I've done that to a guy
and I thought who the hell am I
to say that I felt bad
but then he asked me why and I don't lie
you know I'm gonna be honest with you if
we're in a relationship
[Music]
and um
how did he respond yeah it was hard for
him but then he actually got well like
he started training in the gym he
started eating properly we cooked
together like that's why I think that I
came into his life to help him with that
it's really interesting like the it's
like it seems like men can accept
criticism a lot better than women
because you know it was hard for him
that in the bedroom there because how
dare you did it would you not get
offended if your man was picking
something seriously in the bedroom yeah
which is why I felt really bad when she
told me that story because it made me
think you know what I did that to
someone and I didn't mean it in a
malicious way no well you should have to
go away the question he asked me the
truth he said go tell me I don't like
felt like I feel like yeah I just think
four or five bucks
I didn't just come out with it in a very
good way I was diplomatic yeah I don't
know you needed I don't know
if I'm gonna be really honest is
spiritually attacked me as well it
didn't it didn't just get me physically
it made me feel when I'm the kind of
person when I'm involved with someone I
take on everything like their emotions
they're all right like I feel
so I just want to ask so was you not
attracted to him anymore because of that
but when you got together you said this
is what he was like so surely you would
know I was attracted to him it was
painful to have sex with him oh because
of his hip bones sorry I thought you
said you wasn't finding it attractive
sorry okay it's it's also the it wasn't
sexy yeah yeah that so what's the
longest I'm waiting to hear from a video
she's five months no no I mean each
person what's the longest each person
two days yeah and he's watching like not
even 48 Hours yeah like two days no
that's what I meant because that's what
I meant because if you're in a
relationship
I can't see myself going fine you know
what yeah I think if you've got no if
you used to her clothes me personally
after a couple of days I'm like what's
wrong yeah yeah after a couple of days
intimacy is a big part of a relationship
I think it's easy I think it's easier to
go longer if when you're not living
together like like me and my partner
wasn't living together so yeah that's
why it probably had that
time but if we were living together I
100 believe it would have been sooner
yeah so can I answer your question
though you know when you said oh if
you're a man commented on your body in
the bedroom wouldn't you be offended I
wouldn't
oh no I mean I wouldn't like I just do
something about it it depends on what
they say though and how this is and I
think it's also the heart behind it as
well well no yours as as well as the
heart sorry
um as well as the heart because I trust
my husband so anything that he says I
know it's not like malicious but also
my husband is a bit of an enemy of my
progress because I want to lose weight
and he's very like oh but you look
amazing but sometimes I just feel like
if your partner says oh yeah I'd love if
you like toned up it gives you that
extra motivation to go tone up do you
know I think there's a there's a way of
going around it so it's not like across
the person when you was when we was
doing this and I felt this yeah there's
there's ways around it now my mama just
say you're fat you gotta really do think
about it
I was just gonna say I think it's all
down to approach how yeah I said I agree
with you because if they say you're
getting busy with your guy and anything
oh you're a bit heavy today excuse me
why are you saying it like that well how
do my heaviness and get stronger then
it's just the way that is not funny
imagine
your game
Sorry what'd you say no I was just
saying like if let's say you're in the
moment you know your mind's in a
different universe and all of a sudden
you hear a city coming like you're a bit
heavy today
if he says it is it true
like what does it matter how he says
it's true it's true he's not saying
you're ugly you know constantly in the
moment I don't think that matters if
it's true
in the position yes yes I agree with
that I said I think it's important that
you date guys that like your body type
your body type can change thank God yeah
um
a couple of babies ago I mean you've
grown together as a couple though yeah
so by what she said like he met me one
day he could be like oh but I want you
to go back and go back to that but you
could lose weight you could he doesn't
care but I'm saying if he cared I
probably would be more motivated yeah
that's what I mean it wouldn't just be
like my internal I want to lose weight
but he's like you know can you buy me a
chocolate then he'll buy me like a Duo
but that's just not helpful that's just
you there are a lot of men who still
expect their women to even if she
doesn't look exactly like how they met
before kids they still expect their
women to look somewhat the same
luckily or your man's like you know we
can eat chocolate together or whatever
but there are a lot of men that are like
yeah she's just you know and there are a
lot of women that feel offended by it
because it's like oh well I've pushed
out this baby but like well I just think
sometimes men feel like they can't say
things that are true to us and like we
want them to communicate it in a
feminine way yeah and and they're not
women so when you say like it's how you
say it it's very confusing to guys
because they're like well it's true
[Music]
yeah men are required to be gentle with
women because we are not like them so I
think in the same way we should not
expect men to deliver in a way that a
female would they need to recognize that
they're not speaking to a male so yes I
feel like men should be able to be
truthful but they should do it gently
because they speak into someone chanting
yeah I I just think that women need to
grow our backbone and stop making
excuses because if you affect your fat
if you're gonna put on what you gotta
put on wait mama told me I was four
pound overweight I lost four pounds he's
just the same thing with what she said
he goes hang on a minute you're putting
a bit of weight in you a bit heavy and I
was like yeah you're right
but no no but what I'm trying to say is
that it all depends on your relationship
and how you talk to each other because
word is quite straightforward and blunt
to the point where people like oh my god
did he really say that I'm like yeah and
it's true and I'll tell them yes look at
you begin you know to your comment it
was like uh because you said but did you
feel like that so let's say the woman
disagreed and then he's like okay but I
want you to you know like get fit and
she's like no I don't really feel like I
can't use you if he then stepped out are
you saying that's like wrong or like his
eyes are not gonna wander I mean yes sit
down and work it out like what he has
he's like he's telling you like babe
please go to the gym ask something and I
and I said no I don't feel like it your
resolve can't be then I'm just gonna
step out on if like if there's a resolve
that goes beyond us continuing this
conversation until we're both like not
satisfied but there is some kind of
Middle Ground here what was the middle
ground believe me well again I think
that's a lot of guys feel trapped in
marriages because they don't want their
kids they don't want to put their kid at
every statistical disadvantage they
possibly could yeah so it's like if they
step this is just how they see it it's
like if they step out and you never find
out because they're you're not doing the
things that they ask them to do they a
lot of times guys feel like it's
Justified no I know I know someone that
said because he has a child he will
never leave the he's child's mom
um but if he's unhappy he will go about
his business behind her back but he will
never leave her and I said to him leave
her he said never because my son's there
and I don't want him not not because he
says that she would keep him away from
him it's because he doesn't want his son
to grow up outside of mom and dad lives
here but together they're happy the son
sees happy Parents I don't know because
if they did I think good on him yeah
yeah
what for cheating and staying yeah yeah
okay
there should be some kind of mutual
agreement between the two parents if
that's the case if they're not happy
no him he said him but what she don't
know don't hurt her in it oh no no you
don't think so no because she can get
infected by what she doesn't know might
hurt that's something yeah if he cares
so much about his child he's going to
care so much about his worst vagina you
don't know that because he cares about
his child yeah he's staying that's his
standard he's staying because of his
child he could leave so because his
standards are so high he's not gonna go
out and cheat
and get something for he's going to be
extremely careful because he's careful
anyway that's why he's staying there
I didn't agree
do you guys believe a man can love you
but still cheat yes yeah I do yeah I
really do like long-term cheating or do
you like oh I've slept with this person
and I I've realized I was wrong I think
sometimes they just fall into some
stripper you know yeah but not not long
time long time
and he he reckons all men cheat in a
certain type of way he said my friend
he's my read he calls it like a transfer
window like a window he said I have my
windows I do what I do and then you know
what I go back I'm a good dad I'm a good
husband but that's it but when that
window opens it's open and when it's
shut it's shut I don't think it'll men
cheat neither do I I'm so sorry yeah I
refuse to Mama don't cheat I just I do
think they can sleep with someone else
else and still love you
mathematics I think so but not like a
long-term relationship with a whole
other family yeah exactly a double life
I don't know I really think guys can
love two women at same time yeah I
really like I mean how they did it
throughout all of history and then
you're gonna you're gonna tell me that
all throughout all of history when it's
17 it's one man reproduced for every 17
women that none of them loved their
wives
isn't it there's more men than women so
technically like there's less Amendment
yeah sorry so they have to double up
yeah reproduce with more women
historically 80 of 80 of women have
reproduced historically were only 40 of
men have I think it's not the same one I
think sometimes you find out who's who
when you go to funerals and you find it
who's that that sounds cool yeah but
it's true and that's when you find out
sometime that the man had a whole family
that nobody knew about and I'm not
saying it's right I'm just saying that's
how the world's always been like I can't
I can't change the world I think it
happens more with people older than me
than than now it seems to be like for
the old people I'll say like 60 and 70.
you always know somebody in like
they had somebody down the road they got
a whole other family that's what you
think oh this oh this is sorry go ahead
go ahead no no worries um I think men
and women God has made us differently
speaking to the mic
um so in Islam men can have up to four
wives
because God know who he's who he's
created men men
they're not they're not like us you know
we're maternal we're more loyal you know
that's what we want from a relationship
and that's what we bring to a
relationship whereas for men they're
more protectors providers they're more
um you know go out there and do the hard
jobs that type of thing so for them what
they want is to spr to put it bluntly
spread their seed and have as many kids
as they can and have as many families as
they can and I'm I mean I I think that's
fine because I think that he can love
talking yeah sorry do you think that he
can love all his wives equally well yeah
I mean I mean that's one of the
concentrates of in in Islam if you're
getting married to more than one wife
you must treat her both of them or four
of them all four of them equally so if
you buy this one a car you need to get
four cars so if you can't if you're not
that top guy that can do that you settle
and you stay loyal to your one woman
because when they say I think people get
mixed up when they saw so you can have
four wives you have to be able to afford
four words yes that's why it's a
different yeah you need to treat and the
people the men that I've known that got
other families
they both have nobody's suffering they
all
and you find that the reason why they
don't want to leave the wife is because
I've been together for years and pension
houses and children in college and
everything grandchildren but I've known
people about a secret family tucked away
and nobody suffers because exactly what
those kids are getting is exactly what
those kids are getting oh actually
actually I have a question oh this is
this is a good question okay ways okay
blessing blessing can you pull something
on the screen are you able to do that
okay
um Google just go to Google and put in
um put an average guy the first thing
that comes up it's like a guy in a blue
shirt
don't put on the screen until I'll show
you I'll tell you what it is I can see
the screen
the left on the left yeah yeah I have
zoom in
okay and then put put
um
what's what's that girl's husband's name
um the Blake Lively's husband uh Brian
Reynolds yeah put Ryan Reynolds on the
screen who is that
I'm just curious it was curious the
answer to this question
um okay so you get you guys get two
options two options
um
yeah put him on the screen and put the
other one tell me when you're ready
foreign
[Laughter]
okay are you ready okay so guy on the
left you can be faithful with him and
have a family or a guy on the right you
can be one of his four wives who are you
picking neither no you don't get to pick
neither you have to pick one I'm sorry
okay okay I'm just curious who who's
picking who's picking guy on the guy on
the left who's picking him me all right
one two one two three four five okay and
who's picking Ryan Reynolds
and you guys
two I mean I'm gonna pick Ryan Reynolds
he's more attractive I don't think
everybody's gonna chase him and who
wants the man that everybody else is
gonna watch it's like you know I'm not
gonna be attracted to the other guy it
can be improved Supergirls looks fade
you know not everyone's gonna be pretty
forever Sam looks like his looks will
improved they can't get no words
I could share a house with like Lively
I'll share No I can't share and also
that's another ick of mine I can't if
someone if everyone wants you I do not
want you you could be for everyone like
yeah yeah stay safe I hear that and I
don't share either I can't I don't get
that whole concept of like
what is it called when people are in
those open relationships open
relationships yeah there's like a word
for it I mean yeah I respect it but I
can't be involved in that I don't share
my question that's why I said earlier
they need to stay with the people that
agree with that and they need to stay
with their people yeah I completely
agree with that
okay I'm gonna take a second and read
super chats guys thank you for all the
super chats this show
um also
um a little announcement we are doing
the new show schedule is Thursdays and
Saturdays so that is going to be the
show schedule moving forward
um the only exception to that is the
last weekend of this month so I believe
the 25th
um I'm gonna have a volleyball game so
I'll probably do Friday of that week
um also all super chats are going to be
read over
um what should we do over ten dollars
over ten dollars today so if you have
something you want to read me to read
um yeah Sunday okay sentience men are
required to be gentle with women because
they're not the same well the current
Western ideology ideologues disagree
with Transformers children making those
self-sterilizing decisions and let's not
forget forget women demanding Men read
their minds
um Dax economy long-term Watcher I'm
gonna have to wait until I'm at work
later to watch and listen but I love you
Pearl and Auntie Jenny um zenti it's a
hundred dollar Super Chat
and willful cooperation AKA submission
comes from a position of power which
most women don't realize so when they
didn't want you in their Prime don't
save them in their decline support their
independence and remember paying for
safety is a heavy price both in Freedom
and money sentience
um
modern women will deny their hot girl
summer as limited not by not only by
virtue of them aging but also due to due
to world events when hard times come
equality and feminism female
feminine oh
feminine oppressionism goes out the
window which Kevin Samuels predicted Gus
love language art love languages are for
women and
weak beta men um Sean looking good Pearl
um Gus Our dating strategies are not the
same men want quantity over quality
you're not special there are millions of
beautiful women but not many attractive
men if you can't keep the men you want
you're the problem see Dumbledore a
whole flock of single mothers saying
they wouldn't accept a man with a second
wife he's already accepting that he'd be
your second husband whether you were
married before or not delusional Gus
you're saying you won't be feminine
until someone brings that out of you
it's like saying that I'm gonna wear a
dress and makeup until I find someone
that brings out my masculine side how
delusional can you be see Dumbledore for
a good man to take care of you did you
ever consider that you must be take care
of take care of a bull the definition of
modern woman is zero self-reflection
um sweet potato Mama Pearl Pearl you
look beautiful I love your hair and
outfit today wonderful show as always
glad to see Auntie back you've helped me
see the men's point of view and I'm so
grateful
um I think that's all of them I'm going
to refresh the supers really quick just
to make sure I didn't miss any any also
guys like the video while you're waiting
subscribe to the channel we also have
two clips channels Pearl daily and
just pearly Clips so make sure you go
subscribe to both okay
um
next question
um could you guys
respect a man that you make more money
than
starting here and then go around
and just just uh just okay and just to
give a little preface that means if he
says quick quit your job tomorrow I have
a plan that you'd listen
go ahead
um
I wouldn't respect a man that I make
more money than
um but if I had a man that makes more
money than me and is you know well put
together
um I can see that I can trust his
judgment and I know that you know he's
got good morals he's um he's got good
faith yes if he says stop working that's
what I want I want to sit at home I want
to paint my toes I want to look cute I
want to you know drive a nice car and
um have maids and all of that and if
he's going to provide that for me and
all I've got to do is pop a couple of
Utes out sit at home why not why not I'm
sorry
I don't think that's the typical stand
on Mom's experience
a lot of work are you a stay-at-home mom
yeah I am I am now is that where your
life is like no
no I'm talking about you know
you could still be a stay-at-home wife
on a more normal salary it just means
cutting off like going down if he can
pay our rent and put food on the table
and do everything that you know I would
be working to provide half of absolutely
fine I can do without the maid I can do
without you know all of that let me just
focus on our home you bring the money in
and I'll make our home a home and that
way I will be more happier because to be
honest you know I am a working woman and
I've got a child it's stressful you know
that morning rush to get that little
four-year-old ready and she don't
understand why I'm rushing and she's you
know money money and I've got a Russia
getting in the car drop her off I've
done a whole shift before I've gone to
work and then I've got to deal with
people that I work with and then you
know hard stop five o'clock I need to
stop this meeting I need to rush out to
you know to my colleagues you know I
might look like you know oh don't put
any meetings in our diary after five
o'clock because you know she's a single
mom and there's that stigma that you've
got to deal with so
the short answer yeah okay
um I think I could I think
in reality that I would have to
I don't think it would be easy to
but I would work at it because I don't
like especially with the way it is to
live now I would not leave an
opportunity to make more money
um because my man doesn't
but I will always strive to respect him
um and leave him to do the providing so
essentially if I bought more money into
the house that's just more spending
money in my opinion I would allow him
like I would leave him to his role
basically yeah let me ask you this what
is it like being a stay-at-home mom
wow
do you know what it's it's fine it's
good because
to me I like raising my children is my
priority and looking after my home is my
priority everything else is extra
but as long as I can give myself the
space to do the extra I'm I'm happier
that way if my whole life was just at
home with the kids and maintaining my
house I don't know how happy I would be
only because I had a lifestyle before
getting married that I had I liked and
so I think here I have the best of both
worlds but I think and actually so I'm
confused are you not a stay-at-home mom
I am a stay-at-home mom but I I do bits
on the side so okay I yeah so um I'm a
stepmom coach yeah but my house doesn't
depend on the money I make all the money
I make it's fun so you work from home
yes I'm I'm yeah I'm always at home yeah
I come out to to do a speaking gig or
something like that yeah
so yeah I would strive to respect but he
will always be the provider and I'm okay
with that whatever that looks like okay
and just like you said also to her you
know how you were saying
um you can have a man on like a normal
wage and still be a say at home mom he
doesn't have to be earning thousands
that is very true like I essentially
what we say in our cultures cut your
coat according to your size whatever my
husband makes our life I will maintain
our life according to what he makes and
as long as Anna says he's our are met
there's really there shouldn't be a
complaint
I like you yeah thank you I like you too
um okay so could you respect a man that
you make more than yes
the answer is yes however I want to see
him
being ambitious he has to have a plan he
has to be someone that gets up no money
no that's not that that's not the guy
you're dating no
that's like that's like the women trying
to change men no he's he's making let's
say what's whatever the average salary
is here 35 000 pounds a year
he will always be making thirty five
thousand dollars a year okay this isn't
build a man but what kind of person is
he the kind of guy that wakes up and
plays video games and just you guys he
goes to work okay and makes 35 000 a
year and then comes home sometimes he
plays video games sometimes he doesn't
the same way you know it's like they we
can complain about the video games but
how many girls are on social media for
hours
we're just as bad no you know what
you're right
I think I could because I've been in
that situation and I've been very happy
with
that okay why aren't you with him he's
in Australia oh oh no so this was recent
yeah okay I don't know what he makes
it's none of my business but I know he's
not like the richest guy in the world
but he's lovely and he actually made me
feel safe in every way so how do you
know that you earn more than him I don't
but if I did I'd be okay with it because
he was that wonderful
okay okay so yeah sounds like you need
to go back to Australia finish your
healing well uh that was the plan not
for him though but I would like to see
him again 100 oh do you think you're
healed enough though
um wait I'm confused so when was the
okay so it wasn't the the old guy eight
months ago
yeah that was in June okay and then when
did the the Australia guy come in
literally this month oh oh and he left
to Australia no I was in Australia she
went away to Australia for six weeks see
this is why when men sleep clear with
everything the guy say so this is why
when guys say like you're healing they
just think you I mean they don't have
nothing yeah you're just sleeping with
other dudes
um no because it wasn't quite like that
it took me a long time to even go on a
date with someone like it wasn't until I
went to Australia I considered that I
was just completely
right but you told me you were healing
earlier in Australia yeah and now you're
telling me you met the guy in Australia
it's not it's no hate to you I'm just no
it's fine I'm just observing he's a
Healer and that that if I'm honest
because I said that to him because he
was going through his own thing which I
won't discuss on here that's his
business and I was going through mine
and I said to him for whatever reason I
walked into your life and you walked
into mine because it was an accident you
know I was walking down the street she
goes oh you met him on the street weapon
was I just come back from the gym I was
in a bad mood I smell I was covered in
sweat I was spotty I was like you know
on my period so I was like bloated and I
did not look appealing at all and this
stunning man walks towards me and when I
fancy someone I get shy and I just
looked down
and he starts talking to me and I'm just
like in my head I'm like why today why
today
and then he's like you should smile you
know it looks good on you and then we
were just talking
and um
I felt really good around this person he
made me feel safe there's something
about his energy that just made me feel
really good
and you were able to trust him
it was more
I know that sounds wild because even I
look back and I think how did I do that
to an extent yeah because I said to him
what are you doing later let's go out
it was me that initiated it and then
when he went in to kiss me he said he
asked my permission he's this is after
the date he said can I kiss you you know
he was asking my permission he was
respectful of my boundaries he was you
know
but you know how you said that you were
going through your stuff and he was
going through his stuff you said that
about your ex the one who was obviously
dealing with anorexia you said
um he his traumas and neural traumas
like were able to go together and now
you're saying basically the same thing
this guy yeah yeah it's because I'm
aware I'm not a perfect person but don't
you think that you said you're you're
healing right yeah if you're healing and
then you're now meeting this guy and
you're acknowledging the fact that
you're going through your ish he's going
through his ish and we've meshed
together you're acknowledging the fact
that you're entering the same pattern
again yeah just because the guy is you
know but it's always when you're not
looking for someone they just pop up and
then you click I can't explain it but
they're not denying what you're saying
though you're right but don't don't you
think you should just not that you
should but
I guess what I'm saying is if you want
to heal to have a fruitful relationship
but that's not going to be toxic that's
not going to have any of the repeated
patterns just have that discipline with
yourself and be like actually no I do
really like you as a person but let me
get to a place where I know that I'm
strong with in who I am I'm not dealing
with the same whatever from the last
person and bringing that into the new
person because all that's going to
happen is yeah you're going to be in the
same predicament yeah it's just going to
be a different story I wouldn't say it's
a personal thing on me I'm definitely
strong in who I am but you're right I'm
definitely not over what happened and I
I appreciate what you said thank you I
just feel really professional here I
don't feel self-healing is not healing
but how do how I have it sounds like you
run away to Australia but you can't run
away from yourself how yeah and you know
what that's right that's true because I
caught myself crying in a new city about
the same sorry ish
render therapy yeah
is it is it a male or a female therapist
it's a male oh wow yeah no luck
he's amazing no honestly he would no
he's so sad about it yeah I'm still yeah
but how do you turn that off like every
feeling you need acceptance first you
need to accept that it's happening
I have accepted it it's just because I'm
speaking about it on a plug do you still
like look up his Social Media stuff I
tell you from the day that I broke up
with him I've never stalked him I'm too
proud I would never do that are you
still live in counseling
I don't want to answer that okay but
you're right there is more work to be
done I'm aware of that it's just because
for me to come on a public platform and
speak about it it's like quite raw for
me still do you know what it is
sometimes when you're not ready yourself
the universe just keeps giving you the
same person in different forms that's so
true you're attracting the same kind to
yourself so you need to be alone and
happy within yourself and then put
something that you obviously think is
for you and good for you will come but
you're not ready so that's why the world
isn't bringing you someone I don't I
think right now your subconscious is
just is saying actually I need to be
back in something I need to help them no
because I was even looking for that I do
I love being single and I really love
him I send her subconscience no because
I wasn't looking for him I was walking
down the street I told him to go meet
you at the bar because I enjoyed his
company I'm in Australia you're just
contradicting yourself
how did you know his company by him just
saying hi though do you know what I mean
because I felt good in his presence and
I'm in a new city across in the night
you know that that feeling that you felt
that safe feeling yeah did you have that
with the last person who was your friend
and you just had that feeling and he was
like oh I like this yeah yeah so you
haven't actually gotten over that yeah
no you're right that that same feeling
that same kick that you got from the
last one so you're getting from this you
know what it says that you're addicted
to that feeling yeah yeah you know what
you're probably right can I ask you can
choose not to answer yeah you're quite
personal but before both of these um
have you suffered with stuff within
yourself and then you're kind of using
these yeah to patch that up yeah okay
probably most likely
but that's the first step is
acknowledgment yeah
[Music]
okay where were we in the room with the
money question
okay go ahead if my man was making
um less than me
um yeah yeah significantly less nausea
anymore he would still be my man
probably it doesn't really matter to me
I love the person for the person if it
stopped me from
doing things and living the life that I
wanted to live then I'm not with the
right person if I love someone I love
them for them I'm not really
materialistic about stuff like that is
there a minimum
what figure yeah I mean because yeah to
be honest let's be honest because he's
unemployed if he's unemployed for two
years you're out yeah probably and I
hope you yeah
I'm out but so there has to be like a
minimum what would you roughly say it is
I couldn't I don't know what people earn
and not shift work I couldn't tell you
how much you'd like him to bring out my
boo week or a month not shift work like
what would you like him to bring I'm a
month yeah in a month two grand three
grand
four grand remember you you listen if he
says quit whatever the amount that
sustains us to like be happy but I don't
need like big flashy things to be happy
you'd be happy living in the Caravan
I guess what about what about the Box on
the corner over here no there's someone
there's there's like a couple people in
these boxes over there oh yeah down
there in it yeah yeah
they've got this box set in the roads
I've seen it I don't think I could but
money doesn't determine like the person
for me if that makes sense
I don't know if that answers your
question I no I don't know
there's no minimum like come on no
minimum I don't know think about that I
don't know what people earn for you what
like to have all your Necessities met
um
yeah I live online okay so you know what
it takes to sustain you yeah do you want
him to be a provider basically because
if you do you know you have to know your
minimum surely surely unless you don't
mind providing for yourself then it
doesn't matter at all
yeah can we not come together was that
not an option
is earning less than me yeah so I I'm
I'm saying at what point do you respect
his decision making
so like if he said quit your job
tomorrow I have a plan I'll listen but
if he's a bum and hasn't worked in two
years why the hell would you do that
yeah I would definitely not listen so so
there's a minimum point right yeah
there's a minimum point where and it
doesn't have to be exact you know just
just a rough figure where you would
listen to what he says
I want to see I couldn't tell you I
couldn't tell you a figure okay what
about 30 30 000 pounds would you listen
is that the minimum people just go off
like what it takes to sustain yourself
and then could you live on a thousand
pound a month if he's bringing in like
between three and four thousand three
and four thousand I think yeah that's
fine a year no a month a month oh yeah
that's nice that's fine it's modernized
or something I like it yeah okay um what
about you would you date a guy that
makes less than you I would date a guy
that um
yeah I would but he would have to be
able to like pay the bills what's your
what's your minimum
um I would say for Grand because that's
like enough to like pay bills rent or
mortgage
um can't know that sort of stuff okay
what about you
[Music]
um
I think I would respect him
I don't believe you why don't you
believe me
um oh gosh what's your minimum okay my
minimum
I'll be comfortable with let's say 3K a
month I think that's okay to bring in
um I think it's all down to I don't know
if it kind of relates to the question
that you're asking I think it's just all
down to ambition if he's a bum no she
said no no that's what he's gonna say
this is a problem with women she said
that she's gonna oh he's gonna be a
hiring her one day no he's not oh
he's happy at his job he loves it he
loves it so it doesn't mean he's lazy
maybe he's like a I don't know do police
officers yeah Postman do police officers
yeah yeah oh God I mean I worked out
McDonald's it's all right
I think my Approach generally is a job
is a job as long as it's making you
comfortable then I will respect that
full stop yeah I think that's just it oh
yeah but I mean in terms of like respect
I mean if we're living together and we
have a family and I meant to like
respect all your decision making
if you're not earning at least to cover
what it takes I mean it's like okay if
you're dating a guy that makes 250 000 a
year pounds or whatever it is here
um if he says quit when
I get yeah that's so much money it's
when like when do you want me to but at
some point like it switches to where you
give him more control
because if a bum tells you to do that
you're not going to do it yeah if it
hasn't worked in two years he says quit
you're like what I mean I can all agree
on that though yeah which we all agree
on but like I'm just asking roughly
around what point is it that you respect
his decision making
like roughly four grand a month okay
that's a good question these are things
that you wouldn't even ask yourself oh
yes I'm actually kind of glad that I'm
here I mean if you want to get married
you kind of have to do them now yeah
because it also depends how many kids
you want yeah so like how much does each
kid cost yeah yeah you need to think
about these things while entering a
relationship especially if you're going
to merge into one I feel like women do
don't they yeah like I see them on first
dates exactly like what would our
wedding look like yeah what area are we
gonna move to and the man is just right
there looking at the stage yeah but
we're five years into it she's like oh
today's a nice day
the white picket fence is there yeah you
think about their career ladder as well
all of it yeah 100 and you look on glass
door I think women like for fantasize a
lot oh yeah and think way into the
future that's good because that's how
they help men like Blossom like that's
how women are health system in because
men are very like and women are like oh
but you could do it this way and this
way and like they flower the seeds that
make it grow women have to like think
outside the box because men are very a
matter of fact which is good and that's
why the woman and the man works together
yeah yeah it's like that quote
that's I think it says something like um
behind every great man is an even better
woman or something Have you heard that
one yeah oh yeah that's the most
quote ever I don't think it
should be even better but I think great
women should be there instead but it
kind of oh just the woman that cares
yeah yeah no this is woman just because
every man is this woman his woman Elon
Musk needed a woman to get to where he's
at Richmond get to where they're going
regardless of whether or not they have a
girlfriend dog eat dog for sure it's
like I mean like the guys that are going
somewhere they're gonna go somewhere
whether or not you're there it's just
like women just like to take credit for
doing nothing yeah
I guess I listen I think unless you're
looking at having kids men can just
pretty much
do anything whereas they don't need
emotional support well they do yeah they
don't need it as much as women like I
don't think they need it like women like
to talk about stuff more they're with
their friends what do they talk about
talk about guys talk about feelings talk
about look men are just like straight to
the point we wiggle around a bit more
but it works together
[Music]
um
I like the chorus yeah
and they're not even you're not even
doing it this time you've got a whole
chorus here
they always roast me in the comments
obviously they're laughing because I
think normally it's Pearl and every
woman is doing it I've been trying to
get better I've been trying to use
interview I've been trying
it's like it's a tick I can't no it's
just a thing in it because all the women
are doing it one person made a comment
and I'm just saying listen to the choir
and the choir said hmm
I love that Auntie oh what do you think
I've never been out of a man that's uh
more than me never never
and I've respected every single one hmm
why do you think that is different than
a lot of women nowadays
I just don't really care how much I am
because no
I really imagine is that when I'm out of
a man he's a man so I don't
I don't pay for anything I'd have to put
mine in my pocket even the man that I've
got now
mm-hmm
I still got more than him he's got my
I'm asking that he's got more cash than
me I've got more acid standing
but no I can't I'd have to put my hand
in my pocket for nothing yeah I think as
long as I don't have to put my hand in
my pocket then yeah I have no problem
what is what is the minimum
person Panama if I can make it work you
know our camper oh oh you know I can
make it
so if these people if these women out
here are saying oh they need to do this
oh the man can't afford that you know
what I mean check yourself to do with a
thousand pounds a month how would you
spot that up I'm just curious I've got
wholesalers yeah I mean it's different
because all right then if I had them if
you live in London with a thousand
pounds a month I can live in before I
was living I can do it on 1500. okay
because like 500 is towards the mortgage
yeah kids are not expensive it all
depends do you know what right it all
depends on what you want want them to
wear but nowadays you'll find that
a five pound t-shirt is not gonna cost
you 50 pounds for the kid or because of
the name or the stamp on it and that's
what brings things up or you know eating
out you know you and a burger buy some
instantly and teach your kids how to
make a burger
you know no eating out
no but do you think a thousand pound is
covering bills it's still me now
wow you know I honestly had the same I
had the same thought yo she took me she
took me how what how much did you say
was 35 pounds it was 30 pounds 30 pounds
30 pounds she said A week for two people
yeah she told me she could get a week's
worth of groceries on 30 pounds I didn't
believe her and go to the market yeah
she took me she took me no we went to
supermarket we'd even go to a market
yeah you can do it you just yeah we'll
talk fresh stuff is this tin yes or no
no it was actually good food check out
wife's School episode two okay
but yeah I I didn't believe her I was
like there is no way there's no way but
yeah 30 pounds you have to look for the
stickers the clearance stickers
in the morning we just went in there we
just we just popped in there and we
picked about four things of stickers but
everything else wasn't was it it was
about four things of stickers in the
middle of the day yeah now in the
evening in the evening
it wasn't bad food it really wasn't
right yeah but you have to even though
this month to cover a whole month
including toiletries laundry alcohol and
everything for the month thousand pounds
for the month I'm talking about all the
alcohol as well well laundry toiletries
electric toothbrush everything Frozen
pan then that's it
yeah I'm gonna watch it I'm sold it's
fine
do you guys think that corn you know you
know what that sounds like okay do you
guys think that corn is cheating no
yes no yes
Roxy does it in front I want to see
which is it in front of me or I know
he's there watching if it's here then
it's cheating if it's like yeah you want
to watch it it's like it's like watching
another movie I ain't watching it though
but I think if it's hidden I think it's
cheating because for you to hide it site
must be wrong yeah I agree don't lie
about it fine yeah I feel like you can
he's in one room and he's watching it
and he coming oh you're watching that
rubbish again it's like it's nothing to
me but you wouldn't get mad as long as
he's not he's open with it yeah would
anyone here be mad if their husband
watched or boyfriend watched corn sorry
can I just say something it all depends
what kind it is if it's that sick
perverted kind then yeah oh yeah yeah
yeah yeah
I mean if it's like regular normal
normal yeah yeah any I'll be upset I
don't think I'd be mad or be concerned
because what is it what's what are you
seeking from this variety
but then again to me that's a concern
for me because what Verizon why do you
want variety let's just try this is why
naturally
I'm not saying all men cheat but men
naturally want variety you're telling me
okay you can take the best man in the
world if he had a Bus full of models
waiting for him every day when he got
home every single day begging to sleep
with it most guys are gonna fail
fair enough but I'm I'm putting my self
in it
if you want variety it's a concern if
you if you cannot exercise self-control
it's a concern if I am to exercise
self-control and you don't give yourself
that same parameter is a concern I'm not
saying I'll be angry but if this is
something to iron out it's not something
that oh this is how you are that's your
makeup that's fine because I know what I
want and as far as I'm concerned on the
foundational like morals principal
standards we match and so if we're no
longer matching it's so even bigger
concern and now we're talking about the
longevity of our relationship I don't
think it means that you don't match no
no but it's up because I know what I
would like and I say what you were like
what is that not not to watch that and
if if
you're telling me these are the reasons
why you watch it less eyeing out those
reasons so you don't have to what if you
feel like the reason is just uh I just
like yeah and it doesn't mean he's doing
it every day or even every week knows
why they like it but everyone knows why
they like what they like no one just
likes it and I'm not sure but that's
like but that's like a female point of
view like to man it's just like a
reaction they don't think that much
but then that's not why then that's
that's fine we don't have to but it's
almost like asking men not to be men but
no not necessarily because in my
experience I have what I have not
experienced that you understand so I
can't even speak to it because it's not
like I've been with a man that could
explain his side of it all I can say is
from my once and if this is how you are
that's fine I'm not gonna like say
change it's you're just not for me yeah
it sounds like you're not it you haven't
created a space where they could even
come to tell you that they want you is
that it sounds like if they do it's in
private like they wouldn't even tell you
oh it's effective and this is what I'm
saying I wouldn't get angry to me it
would be a concern so if you came to me
or I caught you I'm not gonna be oh my
no no it's like okay let's sit down and
talk about it like why why why can't you
feel like you like this or whatever and
like if if you like this is how I am and
I can't really explain it or whatever
I have the right to say but I don't like
this I don't I don't have to compromise
on that so hang on can I just say
something because from what tell me if
I'm wrong yeah you're talking about
if like now if you found him watching or
if he suddenly decided yeah but
what I would say yeah and what I think
you're saying is that yeah this is you
wouldn't be with somebody that does it
anyway yeah and then if he happens to be
doing it there's a problem yeah and that
I feel the same way I mean if I know if
I know that my man does it I'm with him
I knew that he'd done it before I got
with him but everyone with a man and
then suddenly he starts doing it what's
going on why all of a sudden you start
you never showed it and I think that's
what you're trying to say because trying
to change an individual is futile to me
okay especially if you do not see an
issue
like I don't have the energy to try and
make you see or even see it from my
point of view if you don't you don't but
I don't have to be I don't have to take
it do you understand or or like I do
have the choice I can I can just
tolerate it like okay this is that I can
tolerate that my point is is then I have
a choice but before me making that
choice I want to sit down and understand
if I had a man it wasn't open about it
in the first place and I found him doing
it
you know what kind can you imagine you
know I've been with you for x amount of
years and you're saying I've always
watched it and I've been like and I'm
now cheating
but then that's choosing to hide it no
yeah that's when I may get angry yeah I
agree but if it's happening
we're going to talk about it okay I just
think a lot of times like from the men's
point of view it's like
we want them to be exclusive to us which
is like compromising on their mating
strategy strategy which is to spread
their seed but on the same time like
when they try to watch and I'm not
saying you specific I don't know your
marriage yeah but like when you tell
them that they can't even watch corn and
that's cheating too it's like well what
do you want from me what can I do so I
just tell them straight whatever they
doing and then I'll try it with you yeah
Auntie's ready to meet them in the
middle yeah I'll attract with you you
know I mean like you want to pick up
some tips but they're not going to watch
it let's let's have a go what's another
freaky stuff you know man don't slap me
either
yeah
I feel like corn has saved a lot of
marriages I've had a partner show me
something and be like
let's try this
really yeah were you down a rematched
she was down
she was down I was down but I it was in
the case where I didn't know that he
wasn't watching it because I knew he
watched it or he'd sometimes be like oh
look at this like he sent it to him and
be like I don't know how I'd feel my
partner showed me really ever sent your
events and let's try this tonight I
don't know I feel like I would be like
and I'm not saying I would be against it
but I I don't know
I think that's about I don't know
obviously everyone's different but to me
for me personally there's boundaries you
can be watching it and doing all this
but if you're putting more attention on
that then me then it's an issue
[Music]
I think that's so badly mine is tell me
the first place because if I find out
later on Wednesday it's just a slippery
slope yeah yeah just tell me who you are
yeah introduce me to you and I'll choose
if I want to be yeah it's awesome I'm
going to show you who I am yeah yeah I
agree as long as you're transparent then
there's no issue what are you on just
let me know no freaky stuff either yeah
yeah
it's definitely important to Arts watch
guy what to ask which kind yeah which uh
because there's different levels and you
find that women might have set up my
accept some levels but then yeah
certain stuff I'm just like yeah yeah
that's who they are as well yeah
your interest I feel like that's a topic
of conversation that you talk about no
yeah I know 100 like I wouldn't know
I've never had that conversation though
yeah I've never had a conversation with
them anymore I've had it what what
they're into yeah
not not in corn I'm saying in in general
in the bedroom like oh yeah you know
what they like and what they don't like
I'm up for anything because you're my
man in it but no freaky stuff
that's different that's not even copy of
nobody that's me getting freaky there's
a big difference yeah
okay I'm gonna take a second to read
super chats guys um like the video on
your way and subscribe to the channel
ring that notification Bell make sure
you're subscribed to both of our Eclipse
channels just pearly clips and pearl
daily
um Maggie The Substitute Teacher oh I
think she's coming on to wife's school
she's going to help us can I say
something please yeah yeah go ahead
early animations
oh I forgot about yeah probably we have
pearly animations now which is like
well you want to explain it awesome your
Clips in animation yeah it's eclipse and
animations and you see shapely Pearl oh
yeah they get a good my cartoon has such
a good body guys I was like I do not
look like that guy
chest hips yeah yeah I was I was like
thank you okay
um Maggie The Substitute Teacher
um thirty dollars for a whole week of
groceries
um Russ thank you for the Super Chat
Liberty now cheers to England hello from
America question for England what is the
definition of Liberty and does it matter
please be specific
um James Pritt found the woman of my
dreams got engaged but bedroom got cold
started getting a lot of offers so I
broke things off but I didn't think I
could trust myself haven't found
anything close to that should I have
just cheated no he did good he did the
right thing I mean if they're already
having issues before they're married
be free
okay Maggie The Substitute Teacher new
to the show just saying hello to Pearl
blessing and Auntie Jenny appreciate you
all
um Eugene Steele I am not considering
myself a passport bro but I wouldn't
mind traveling to the UK to meet the
woman in Olive Green
[Laughter]
she's single sentience
um men are required to be gentle with
women because they're not the same while
the car oh I think I read this one
already okay let me refresh it really
quick guys
um also guys I think we're gonna do I
know
um I know I announced that I was going
to do our 1 million party next month
I was too ambitious okay I was very
ambitious I was like let's do it next
month we can do it it's happening in
June I think June 10th I'm gonna
finalize it this week
but yeah yeah it's not happening next
month sorry guys too much planning yeah
estimated how much work is yeah I didn't
realize how much like it takes the
throne event together and like the
tickets and everything yeah
that's that's my fault
um
okay
I'm trying to think of my next
question
um
oh no if they when they get married what
kind of wife do they think they're gonna
be oh that's a good question auntie go
ahead and start there
[Music]
definitely a calm wife I know that
sounds like what is a calm wife but just
someone who like keeps their home
peaceful no outside dramas
um and just
a loving nurturing place like I want
like I know in the UK you get like that
I think like 10 to 12 months or
something for your maternity leave I
want at least the two the first two and
a half years just with my kids at home
and I kind of want them close in age and
just
I know it sounds so like cliche and like
the cooking the cleaning Vibe I just
want it to be a place where my mind can
feel like he can be a man and like he's
in his role and his masculine and I can
be in my feminine and just be a mother
and a wife that's literally what I want
what do you think you're gonna get
that's what I'm going to get okay yeah
that's what I'm going to get I but I
need a man who wants to be a husband and
wants to do that role I can't have a man
who wants me to also be like so what
would your like day-to-day like life
look like if you were in that role like
what would you be doing right from one
time you wake up in the morning with the
two kids at six o'clock in the morning
what should they gonna be like well I
have my my own daily structures and then
that can just put me in the mind frame
of doing what I need to do and with kids
you know it's never gonna no day is
gonna look the same but
all right then you wake up at five
o'clock in the morning one baby's
screaming you've got to get your husband
ready for work you you have a guy across
from you who makes 250 000 a year he
says you know you could be my you could
be my housewife what are you gonna do
for me go
cook clean make sure the kids are looked
after and when I say and also keep
myself together
normal day from start to finish okay so
I wake up a VJ
like get stuff out of my journal
meditate do my like seven self-care
pillars cold shower if that means I
gotta wake up at four because the kid
wants to scream at five then I gotta do
that
one two kids one might be in school one
might be Nursery or two under two I
don't know
um
homeschooled
homeschooled until what age whatever me
doing it or like someone comes in oh I
do you know I've never
um actually thought about like what that
would look like but I would be happy to
I've never thought about what that would
look like I've always just kind of had
in my head that my kids would be at home
until about three four I personally
don't want my kids going to Nursery at
two I know that's like this kind of like
standard age but I I want to be at home
with my kids at two years old so about
three four they can like start going to
to other people I okay my kids can't be
looked after by other people until they
can put a sentence together
um yeah yeah like that that that's it
until they can understand like their
body in terms of like for that age
they're not being looked after by anyone
and I need a man who gets that who says
you know what yeah I agree I don't want
a man to think oh you doing that means
you're going to live off of me no I'm
doing this because of the nurturing and
the foundation I want for my kids I'm
not sure because I'm going into the
world if the child is really ill and you
go to bed at midnight are you still
going to get up at four o'clock in the
morning to go for your whole
yeah I'm just thinking myself you would
love to have that couple of hours in the
morning to do all of that all of that
stuff it just sounds amazing if they're
sick sorry sorry no I mean because
you're gonna say you're going to get up
at four o'clock in the morning if I had
because
um I was doing a lot of talking about
how did you say about your day yet it's
been a lot of
I don't know here I wanna I'll tell you
what I want to hear right like you said
you get up at four o'clock in the
morning
you do all of your stuff you're for you
what time's that finish
45 minutes to an hour all right then so
five o'clock we can do that
I mean I'm not a mother so I don't
exactly know what that looks like but I
know that I'm prepared to do whatever it
takes to be the mother that I know that
I want to be so I I can't I how have you
how have you prepared what do you mean
no I said I I'm prepared to do it okay
so like you would have to teach you what
do you mean so you see I'm saying so
then he would have to teach you you're
prepared to do it but you're not telling
me what it is yeah I I yeah I I don't
know exactly I know it takes a lot
emotionally mentally physically
um and I'm ready to and I'm prepared to
go through it I I want to go through it
because I want to be a mother have you
got nieces and nephews
um I do do you babysit a lot not not
like that no
would you be able to if you could yeah I
could it's half term this week try it
try it for a day yeah all of them try
having them for a day yeah I would let
me know how you can I would be down for
it let me know how you go
I think my siblings are they they range
in a massive range so I want you to have
all the ones under five
okay and let me know how you get one for
a full day no parents involving but in
the morning they drop off to the evening
bedtime I would love to do that let me
know how you get and I'd love to know
okay so then we get 5 a.m so the kids
like I don't know how long the date is
gonna be but I know it's going to be
yeah
I mean because
finding time to like have your shower
and all that and you might not even have
time to to do all of that stuff and then
to you know have dinner ready for when
he gets home like I I know it's going to
be stressful and I know it's not going
to be an easy job like I'm not even
gonna pretend like I'm deluded on that
but I just can't wait to be in it I
think you need to start practicing now
that's what I mean yeah it sounds
wonderful because I can't wait till we
get down to the end so you can hear what
it's really like
yeah
but then also I'm how many how many
meals can you cook would you say like if
you were to make a menu of your food how
many meals oh I don't know but in double
digits okay so like 10 20. yeah know
which one 10 20 or 50.
um like 15 20 25 okay okay cool so he
gets 25 meals
really and oh yeah no I'm just asking
yeah yeah okay
if you have any other questions Auntie
no I just want to know
well I know when you said I'm about um
when it gets to the end but I also know
that I won't be in that position unless
I know that he can provide a certain
lifestyle
you can never afford to have children I
know if you think you're gonna save up
to our children forget about it I'm not
but I can afford categorically tell you
if if life happens and we might end up
in a situation but I can categorically
tell you I'm not entering a situation
like that no there's no baby leaving my
body without a ring on my finger can I
come to your wedding of course I die of
course you can okay there's nothing
wrong with having kids without marriage
I mean I was born outside of marriage
but it's not happening for me it's not
are you religious
are you religious I'm a Christian yeah
okay then that just changes things a
little bit why
before she said that's the key that's
then the chance
it's very rare now at least she's got a
there's a percentage there not very high
but this sort of percentage you don't
stand a chance for what kids no for the
happy were ever and the regular out
there and the way the way she sounded it
just sounded like impossible yeah it
just doesn't sound like real I don't
know it depends I can't yeah
not having kids before marriage no no no
I'm gonna wake up for an hour and
meditate before my kids not meditate for
an hour oh my God no like 45 minutes no
I mean like everything that I do like
right now currently everything I do
takes about 45 minutes in the morning
that's from waking up to having my
shower meditate VJ breakfast but well
sometime yeah oh sorry journaling it's
just where you just like get like but
it's not like happy Journey it's just so
you get any like horrible thoughts out
and the emotions so it's just you just
get out it's done leave it there don't
carry on into the next day you don't
carry in into the day why wouldn't you
just play pardon no I pray as well
um and I sometimes I do it twice a day
sometimes I do it once a day it really
depends
um but I'm just I don't need to take
negative emotions from one day into the
next day and sometimes a lot of times
when you think something's happened or
someone's done you something they
actually haven't it's just you're in
your feelings and you get it out and
it's and also instead of offloading onto
another friend not all the time do I
need to call my friend I'm like oh my
God can you believe this happen and
they're like yeah oh my God if that
being just get it out boom done move on
what would you do for your husband every
day because I've heard about the kids
I've heard about you I haven't heard
about your husband yet
like clean okay outside of that anything
else
be his support system okay how I don't
know what that look exactly what that
looks like but if he told me it looks
like x y z then it's XYZ okay okay
um what about you what what kind of wife
do you want to be
I feel like um I was born quite maternal
quite wisely and I
sometimes it's a con because you carry
worthy duties before when you did
girlfriend prices when I am a wife
um I have kind of similar views I'll you
know I want to raise my children to a
certain age and then they can get into
education or whatever
um if during that time my man is the
provider then I'll have to step up and
do most homely things but then when I do
continue to go back to work or start
providing also whether it's for everyone
or just you know partly
um I'd want him to step in slightly more
and maybe one night help with the
cooking or unload the dishwasher I don't
think it should be all on me
um
but yeah I'm a very given person I'm
very caring nurture in person so
whatever he needs if you need help
within his worker you know I'll always
try I won't I won't ever say no or
decline anything I always try okay could
I get more specifics because this is
just very broad specific in what like
what what exactly you would do every day
like as a wife
and you said like you did this stuff at
like wifey things at girlfriend oh yeah
what does that mean no cook I clean you
know and I'd wake up make the bed if do
you think do you think a man paying for
a date is doing husband things at
boyfriend prices
do I think a man paid every day yeah I'm
paying for a date is that doing husband
things at boyfriend prices because a lot
of times I think like we say we cooked
we cleaned and that's that's wifey
things at girlfriend prices but then
they protect and provide possibly yeah
okay so you think a man shouldn't pay
unless he marries you no I don't think
that but if you know I'm choosing to
cook and clean you can choose to pay if
you want to pay if you don't want to pay
I'm not getting onto you about that same
way if I don't cook you're not going to
get on to me about that we're not at
that level yet they might get under you
about it they might they have the choice
to but I also have the choice to you
know but I feel like if you don't
display that you can do those things
then you're not going to get to that
marriage stage
just start looking after the kids not
necessarily but I just mean like the
cooking and the cleaning that's a
slippery slope because women then like
they want to show you all they've got in
their locker and then they're always
like oh I might as well just chill like
this okay get used to it yeah that's not
something why is it that when women talk
about doing stuff for a man the first
when they talk about is cooking and
cleaning like a man can't do it yourself
they never talk about I want to hear but
the men can cook and clean nowadays
every man can't cook and clean you
shouldn't be with them your husband can
cook and clean he's got cake ball
looking after himself so he's got the
kids they're just talking about doing
something that a man could already do
for himself what's the next suggestion I
don't think there's any right or wrong
answer for that I think everyone's
everyone's marriage is going to be
different I think we're all saying the
right things
personally that's how I feel I think
just add to each other's life when you's
not getting married invite me please I'd
like to see what's that that's all I'm
saying invite me I can't wait to get
married I can't wait for you to get
married I love you I can't wait for you
to get married I can't wait what would
you suggest adding to the resume
I know there's some things that we've
been working on like we're making a
cookbook I think they need to um
oh well the nieces and nephews two and a
half term it's half term if they live on
their own then get a couple of days off
have them ran let the parents just leave
them there then get on with it listen I
understand it's not just cooking and
cleaning like I've for example been a
nanny before I'll give him sex every
night as well yeah on top of the cooking
and cleaning and looking after the kids
and doing the shopping and getting all
the delivery done and so in that all
these paperwork is that what we were
missing sex
what do you think a man would say
your life is you
decided to merge both your lives
together and then you
drew it
[Music]
it's not like you have one role and I
have one role we just we're doing it I
feel like fits I do feel um I I think in
my marriage I definitely feel like that
would be set roles yes
I was gonna say if the man was at home
all day and you've got all them kids in
that you're still gonna fit in six room
though
yeah when they're napping
what's their nap
there's ways around it
I think the kids love like was it cocoa
melon and whatever just talking melon
Grace Grace's corner of them yes they're
walking you know Jump Around everything
Peppa Pig comments are saying that these
answers are very vague I don't even know
what they're saying
well I'm not gonna go into like you know
okay as a non-married woman there's
people saying I'm being vague
I would wake up make sure everyone's
alive and well I'd start going about my
day think about what I'm gonna do if I
have children I'm getting them ready if
my husband's going to work and I'm still
looking after the kids at home he can go
off to work you okay if you eat and cool
never know about your day be on about
your way I'll take care of the kids if
we've got any stuff coming up try to
take them for a walk hopefully the
dishwasher's done by the night before
empty it out go about my business think
about what I'm gonna cook look in the
fridge start preparing that one's
watching TV One's in their little Walker
they're about my day yeah it's lovely
how's your day as it is now
would you don't forget to change your
nappies live in now all right then let
me let me just see if this matches right
go on you wake up early in the morning
I'm just talking as a grandparent when
I've got the grandkids right
I'll be getting dinner ready the night
before so I wake up about four half four
in the morning do me meditation for an
hour half hour not an hour oh my gosh
you can stay focused for that long
exactly that's your problem one
and I do half past four in the morning
and then I will start getting the
clothes will be sorted from the night
before dinner be ready for the night
before Pearl knows that my dinner is
cooked by nine o'clock in the morning
and one of the dinners cooking the kids
are dressed they're washed and they're
dressed and then we all have breakfast
together
and then I might have to take them out
or do some kind of work with them go in
the garden and do bits in the garden
then it's lunch then it's painting then
it's crossed and you've got to clear up
and then you've got to think about
calming down everybody have dinner
together just look at the washing up you
still got the washing to do you still
got the housework to do and
get the kids ready for bed sort out
dinner for the next day spend time with
your husband and still got to give him
good sex and still wake up early in the
morning does it sound like like a day
add the extras that you put in because I
know you're busier than that I'm just a
grandmother in my head that's what the
day sounds like I just couldn't I just
couldn't get it out because I don't yeah
I can imagine no I know that's what I'm
trying to because it sounds like oh
wonderful but we're just I just want to
show you reality but it's not wonderful
yeah I don't think it's wonderful at all
you've got one baby in one hand you're
trying to stir something in the other I
understand that wonderful it is
wonderful like it's wonderful but at the
same time like I'm not saying it's going
to be in this easy smooth ride and I'm
just gonna be like oh we got the morning
I'm Gonna Learn after my kids and like
no obviously they're all you are going
to go through your own internal
struggles and battles and Mentor as well
but I'm just saying nobody cares about
that when you're a wife and a mother I'm
I'm just saying that I don't mind I
wanna I wanna I wanna hear what wait
could we uh oh yeah no I want you to go
because they've both been married so
they could both so I want to do the
single people first okay
um what kind of wife do you want to be
oh off the sorry I did that thing where
you breathe in the mic I think off the
basis of my previous relationships and
from what I've learned
because I'm I've never been married I
think
I could provide emotional support moral
support
um
So when you say emotional support I need
to know exactly what that is if you're
gonna come to me and tell me you have a
mental disorder or if you know anything
you want to keep dating guys with mental
distance no but you know
I don't believe in a perfect person okay
okay we're gonna get a sane one but yeah
right right
and I just want someone lovely that
doesn't stress me out okay and if I have
that you just you just picked the guy
with the mental disorder I don't looking
they just find me maybe maybe it says
something about me anyway but okay right
I would provide a safe space for them to
be honest with me about anything so we
can have conversations rather than
arguments I think that's important
that's really important okay so how
would you do that what is that I'm very
good at resonating with people I can
call myself out and self-reflect I have
the capacity to do that when I know when
I'm wrong so so if he he says something
to you then you'll say I was wrong yeah
okay if I was wrong yeah okay because No
One's Gonna Die saying that okay so
you're able to say you were wrong yeah
it's just when you're talking it's very
vague so I'm just trying to make it more
specific yeah I'll give them the safe
space to know that we can have those
conversations where they can call me out
or I can call them out and we couldn't
come to a conclusion so so you'll say to
him I'll admit when I'm wrong yeah okay
so that's the safe space as you'll admit
as long as I have that back in return
for me to feel yeah yeah okay but you
won't do that unless he says I was wrong
too I would do that but I'd expect it
back I worded that so incorrectly my bad
um so that
um I'm very very very passionate
um I'm fun so I don't think anyone could
be bored around me when they know me
what does your day look like thank you
as a wife what would your day look like
you wake up like this sounds great for a
girlfriend
fair enough but as a wife oh god I've
never I haven't bought this for a long
time you're applying for a job right
it's like if we if you're applying for a
job you're gonna have a resume if these
are the skills I've had this is the
experience I have doing that you might
say like nanny for two years that'd be
great you know whatever I have been a
nanny actually okay but doesn't it
really kind of depend on the person
you're with to answer that question
correctly I mean if if I apply I can
apply for a shitty job and a good job
but I'm going to interview the same yeah
it's your CV what your what you're
bringing to the table like you want to
answer me I'm gonna I'm gonna cook
home-cooked meals and stuff like that I
mean it would be nice to know exactly
what home cooked meal like the more
details the better so yeah
predominantly being West Indian food If
I Loved Someone that much to marry them
I would learn to cook what they want to
eat I would my question is what do you
know now so again this is like going to
a job and saying hey I'll learn whatever
you want to teach me and then they're
like okay what skills and experience do
you have and you're like well I'll learn
whatever you say
if okay I'm loyal I know that I'm very
loyal I'm very honest I'm very loyal and
those are my those are she asked what
your day is looking like okay yeah all
right
um I think it's okay to say I don't know
as well I don't know my life but I'm
really not that sure yeah that's an okay
answer yeah I'm in the Arts like my life
I'm gonna be honest my life is chaotic I
wouldn't want to marry me I would not
want to marry me so I haven't actually
thought in depth about that question I
don't think I'm a good candidate to
answer that okay do you want to get
married though yeah I in good time but
not for a long time we have a school
teach me
season two does this does the school
have like husbands it might I don't know
we're open we we're bless it has to go
to school
um okay that's that's good what about
you
oh she's see you you've had the the
privilege of Love yeah right
um
I think with me
I think one word to summarize I I think
I'm going to be very transparent as a
wife
um I would say well if you look at like
my day-to-day life as of now like I'm a
very busy person like I work a nine to
five in a very very stressful industry
so I'm always out of the house like
pretty much five days a week and if it
comes to a thing where like let's say my
husband likes a freshly cooked meal once
I get home I'ma keep it real look I'm
tired I can't cook for you today
I like to kind of maybe plan ahead just
due to my hectic life so as it is you're
a crack are you a crackpot Crack part
type of girl crap no she means that slow
cooker yeah like oh yes no there's a
slow cooker
because I like my food to taste good so
obviously with that being said yes I
will tell I'm a slow cooker because it
involves a little TLC so I need to make
sure that how many meals would you say
you cook a week now oh God uh so like
this week how many meals did you cook
I'd say two two okay how many meals did
you cook this week Pearl
at least seven at least seven I've been
doing better she's Banned Me from
takeout yeah that's why I asked that
yeah um so I think and I think with me
as well I'm the kind of person like
um when it comes to my emotions I'm not
afraid to hide it I'm gonna like kind of
tell you what's up I'm not really kind
of bottle it up because I just don't
think it's healthy to bottle things up
do you think that's valuable to a guy a
girl that's gonna tell him his her
feelings all the time how are you doing
this
[Laughter]
job interview yeah and he's saying okay
what are you what's on the resume and
you say I'm gonna tell you my feelings
and that's how they're going to hear it
I'm just letting you know
I mean I don't care yeah
once you've got them I think you need to
understand them to the point of how you
communicate to them I think that's just
the best way I can approach it I think
I think with me like I think when it
comes to emotions let's be real like
when when it's raw sometimes you don't
think things straight away you might
just say things and just blah just
impulsive and then if like you're trying
to express these things to a guy let's
be real he's probably gonna absorb 50 of
what you're saying
not even that 20.
I think I need to keep up with the times
so that's just an average figure I had
in my head but you know I'll wait I'll
get back into reality soon
um but yeah I think I think that's just
one way for me to just kind of summarize
everything just being transparent and I
mean if it's a thing where like kids are
involved and stuff then
I don't know would you quit your you
seem like you like your job a lot you
seem very career driven yeah I am yeah I
know and that's fine would you quit that
to raise kids
uh no yeah
I don't think I would I don't think
she's gonna be a working wife yeah
definitely mama what's what so then
who's gonna raise the kids
Nursery
grandparents that's what they're there
for no so you want your parents to raise
your kids I mean oh God
I don't want them to raise them but I
want I know they're going to be heavily
involved in my kids either your parents
are a stranger oh that's so true right
uh I'm just telling you how men hear it
yeah it's true oh
it's a hot question it is a very hard
question okay let me just say I don't
know it's really not a heart it is a
hard question
woman it's a very hard question it's not
a hard question it's just it's just a
heart it's like it's just the answer
maybe doesn't like reflect in the way
that men would want to hear and and also
no one's judging you it just it's how
you feel you may even change your mind
but for now if you feel like yes I'm
gonna utilize nannies the school system
that I'm gonna utilize all of what I can
afford because I love my career I liked
working I changed my jobs I mean yeah I
think I think if I'm being honest now
probably strangers so like nannies and
the nurseries and all that stuff will
probably be strangers getting involved
with raising my kids but who knows in
future I could probably change my mind
so in the future you might not be able
to afford it oh my God
the way the prices are now yeah I had
nannies so it's not yeah no in England
it was it about a thousand pounds
um a week yeah it's a nice
I'll be honest Like Me growing up we had
Au pairs is that how you oh that's what
we had actually we had the same thing
they just most people don't know that
word yeah yeah yeah Alpine is a
different they're cheap but they live
they're cheap and they live in yeah yeah
so yeah oh my gosh there's so many
stories of like
not not we never had this issue with our
pairs but
Au pairs in the area where they would
like sleep with the husband yeah
because you're put you're basically
putting a wife in your home no I mean
she's raising your kid she's cooking the
risk is there we never had that but we
did have one au pair that stole my
grandmother's jewelry oh yeah we had we
had one that married my cousin yeah I'm
more than I married my uncle and one
that did Cam work I mean we had like 20
years
I I have nine siblings
go no no I get why you're vocal though
because in a big family you have to be
hard yeah I'd say everyone in my
family's entertaining and funny because
it's like either entertaining or funny
because otherwise you didn't get any
attention
and everyone's like good at like like
very good at something because it was
like how else are you gonna get your you
know you got these kids oh my gosh
um okay thank you
um okay tell me about being a wife your
day yeah tell me what your day is like
so I wake up between 6 and 6 30 to do
Bible study
um and see my husband off to work and
yeah you feed him before he goes to work
yeah oh no he doesn't like eating okay
yeah he's not for us I mean he might
like grab cereal or something but he's
not really fast to be honest and I don't
make him pack lunch he's just he's not
fast so I used to but yeah but
um he yes I see my husband off and as of
six weeks ago my daughter decided she
wanted to go secondary school so now I
see her off to secondary school and my
husband takes her and then after I do my
Bible study a child will catch me go
upstairs brush their teeth and get them
fed and then um we'll listen to some
music and then after some music
um and performance time mommy watch me
then we'll get into homeschooling
so I homeschool three of the kids and
then my oldest one goes to how long does
that take you every day for the
homeschooling I'm just curious oh it
fairies on on average about four hours
four hours a day on the average year but
then it just depends on the kids
sometimes they they're not with it so
um yeah and then it comes to lunchtime
which is around the time where I make
lunch I make dinner and then I get the
kids to tidy up
and then we go out get the sister from
school then we come back sister does the
homework her homework then she tells me
her stories and like we have a little
bit of mom and daughter time kids are
playing and then we um tidy up again
before dad comes home depending on what
I look like I'll either like spruce up
or if I've got stains on my clothes I
quickly change just so like I look
presentable then oh thank You
Usher husband in then he comes and then
the kids do their whole dancing acts Oh
Daddy you watch me this is what I did
today and I leave them to it then he'll
join me in the kitchen while I prepare
everyone for dinner and that's when he
will ask me is do you need help with
anything and if I do I'll give him my
list if I don't then he'll go back to
the front room after our little chat
then we have dinner and then
um the kids before the kids go to bed or
like do like a devotional together
um everyone prays for each other then
the kids go up to bed then my husband
will go up and pray for them and I sit
down and broke his necklace process then
my husband comes back down then we sit
we chill we watch a movie we laugh
whatever and then
if I'm being honest he'll probably go
out to bed first and then I sit down and
process and then force myself to go to
bed to when my body is exhausted and
then I go to bed and stuff may happen
at night stuff may not happen at night
then I do all over again and on the
weekend then the stepsons come over and
then there's football and then there's
church and then this food bank
she's something do you have time to go
to the club in between I'm just curious
no but I did but like honestly when me
and my husband want to get to liveo like
we just pick what the date nights are
gonna look like so it's like it could be
like a chilled one or it could be like
oh this are you saying you don't have
time to go to the club on the weekends
do not have time to go to the club oh no
actually I do have a mommy's day off let
me not like every every day in the week
I do have a day off to myself where I I
run away and that's usually the day that
my husband works from home so then he'll
have the kids and he'll work from home
and I'm somewhere with a girlfriend or
something but then if that can't work I
will book an evening on a weekend and I
will go out with the girls but yeah yeah
that's what it looks like do you go
Carnival no
really I thought traditional women went
to college
we're all from Ghana and what meals can
you cook
English meals African meals West India
Mills Indian Mills
yeah any well to be honest what I if I
fancy it I'll learn it I'll learn to
cook it so I
technically I can cook anything yeah
but like in my locker I I can cook a
variety of milk and what what Lifestyle
Changes did you have to make from being
single to being married so they were in
the beginning there was two incomes
and I said to my husband I well I was
pregnant at the time I was like tell my
husband said what's gonna happen with
the baby because I don't I didn't want
to do the nasty thing like because they
can't speak I don't know what's
happening
um and he was like well I'm not gonna
stop working and I said okay well you
can go part-time and I can go part-time
he was like no
so I didn't go back to work because I
want to be with my kids and he wouldn't
yield so I didn't have a choice it
wasn't me wouldn't you he wouldn't go he
wouldn't go part-time you really
expected him to say yes a little
came into being a wife it was a big
shock to the system because the things
in my head was not what it was in
reality honestly I I don't know a man I
don't I I know what it's like a man to
be like so I asked him with I came
boldly that's like a masculated you work
part-time I work part-time on the same
level in my head it's like yes yes we
are on the same Guild and he was
unyielding and then I was with the
dilemma I love him I leave a goal and
carry on working and park my kids or I
stay at home with my kids and stayed at
home with my kids and it worked and what
changes you have to do from the two
wages two incomes to one
so full transparency and I hope my
husband wouldn't mind but he makes the
money and he hands it all over to me so
I know what I'm working with and what I
want and what I don't want and I just I
work with what I have Jonathan she's
she's calling me ain't she you know
women work with what their husband
brings in that's basically isn't it
praise God my husband's like that
because I don't think I would be like
calm if I couldn't see money but like I
on his payday it's my payday because the
work drops in his account and
by midnight I'll see my bank account
fluctuate you mean you don't have to
begging about asking for money no
because I I I I divvy up the money so
he'll keep what he needs I was just
saying that because somebody said that
in traditional women when they don't
work in their houseworks it means that
they're slaves and they have to beg the
husband no
no no no
because I have all the money so if I and
my husband trusts me so if I if I want
to spend the money on a shopping spree
he knows everything else is covered how
did you how did you know you wouldn't
just be destitute
he could just leave you destitute high
and dry I mean to be honest he still
could and my mom has said to me now have
a private pot there that he doesn't know
about um
just in case he leaves you high and dry
kind of thing but like you can't get
nowhere you ain't going nowhere if he
does it I'm coming after him I mean I
just I don't like like you said about
um not holding on to negative thoughts
and stuff like that I mean what is the
point I'm living life for today so I'm
just gonna live chinch you know what I
mean do you feel like your marriage
could have still worked if you weren't
able willing to give up control
no because they said this is what I'm
saying when I got into my marriage I was
very controlling more controlling than I
ever could understand and I started to
change because he started to change
because he told me I I'm suffocating him
that's what he said to me and it made me
feel sad so like I had to work it out
but my excuse was my big crutch was well
I've been a single mom so I had to
control everything and I didn't have a
man I'm working out but actually I was
unyielding like I did not want to
like
I was not nice man did you have a couple
of counseling no we didn't he didn't
want to go
you just worked out how long did it take
you to have that switch would you say
she's still switching no not really I'm
still working honestly I'm still working
out but I think I'm just not defensive
anymore so he could say like babe like
kind of thing and I'll be like oh okay
sorry but at the same time like he had
some passive Tendencies as well and I'll
be like babe like make a decision and
he'll be like listen I've got it I'll
get back to you whereas before it'll be
like well I don't know I don't know I
don't know so like we're still working
out but as the years go on like I say
like this is our eighth year into
marriage it sounds like you're going
like that that you used to it like that
that was you yeah that was him yeah and
it was somewhere yeah
I was somewhere where make it we've made
it to middle ground and now we're just
like maintaining it like sometimes I go
left sometimes he goes left but we know
where our Middle Ground is and like we
maintain it it it's it it's an ongoing
thing it's a journey it's not his
destination marriage is hard work you
need to work at it that's what it is
yeah yeah and like like commit so
there's times where my husband has not
been working there's times like when
things have been hard there's times when
I have not been touched by him like
there's we've had everything that you
can think of and then obviously because
we're a blended family you've got that
them difficulties to iron through but
like when I say that we're committed
like we are committed so I'm angry with
you I do not want to talk to you right
now but I'm not going anywhere yeah have
you got a big vehicle you've got two
vehicles I've got a seventh CR okay yeah
I was like where is she putting all
these kids in the end I would like her
might like another vehicle but yeah okay
I grew up with like a 16 passenger van
and it was like yeah it's like one of
those big yeah again I'll need a van for
sure yeah we have to let go of the cars
yeah yeah you guys don't really have
them as big of cars here no I think it
got it like the car vanities go up to
like nine seaters yeah until you have to
like Minnie Mouse yeah minibus
uh what about you what what kind of wife
were you and what type of wife would you
like to be
um so I was a
confused wife
um
a masculine wife a wife who
so for context I'm the eldest so I had
this I just want to say something before
I want to hear you about your day-to-day
because I know that you're going to be
struggling with what you're going to say
about your husband that's why I can see
you're picking and choosing so I just
wanted to let you flow with yeah what
your day-to-day life was like then and
what your date and what you'd like it to
be like because I know that you're gonna
met trying to respect things so I'd
rather that you just sit rather than put
yourself in it I'd rather you just say
like what did you do like get up in the
morning because you said you were doing
everything so just tell us your
day-to-day as as you were yeah so
pre-baby I mean I think we had
uh six months of marriage before I got
pregnant and then obviously nine months
so you know just over a year of just us
and it was okay wake up in the morning
no before do you wake up I mean I've
always worked so ever since I turned 16
you get your ni number I've always
worked and I've studied and then I went
into my career so it was always a wake
up at six A.M
um work out
um shower go to work come back and you
know the usual single life you put your
feet up you eat and then do it all again
I mean but when you got married before
you had the baby yeah what did you do
then same because we were working
different uh so he was doing shift work
obviously both yeah so he was doing
shift work and I was the corporate nine
to five so there's days where I'm going
to work in the morning and he's not
there or I'll come home and he's not
there
um who's cooking he was cooking me yeah
I was cooking but that's what I mean you
didn't say anything you just made it
says I got up but I've done my stuff and
I went to work and I come home yeah I
was thinking at what time did you wake
up and start cooking for your husband
because this sounds like Separate Lives
I would come home from work and on the
weekends I would meal prep so you know
us somalis we like to have like our you
know um our big lambs and chickens and
stuff so I'd cook that on the weekend
freeze it in like little pouches so I
know Monday Tuesday Wednesday Thursday
Friday is like what we're having
and so then all I've got to do is the
rice and the pasta or whatever it is
um and he would always come home and
there's always food even if I'll go to
sleep and he's finished at 11 or
whatever I've got his play everything
done the microwave his cup drink next to
it everything just set up for him so
when he comes home he can just eat shall
we will come to bed
um there were days where we would spend
time together so we'd end up coming home
at the same time and I'd we would both
make it our duty to spend time together
then and you know cook together sit down
and eat because you know that you we're
still in our honeymoon period you know
we're still getting we're happy anyway
baby comes
um not long after covid came so I still
kept up with those duties and I
essentially was a stay-at-home mum for a
year for maternity leave so what that
would look like is
um whenever he's getting up to go to
work I'll make sure I have food ready
for him so his breakfast is ready
um at the time you know I've got a
three-month-old six month old however
older she was at the time but I'd always
make sure that he left with his stomach
full and would come home and his stomach
is full
um
we'd spend time together as a family
when he comes home from work and then do
it all again tomorrow so and I really
enjoyed that part and I actually got to
be you know more feminine I wasn't as
stressed
um you know because when you come home
from work you don't want to be was that
in the year that you enjoyed now the
coverage year did you enjoy it because
obviously did go out you didn't go out
to work during the covid No No this was
pre-covered so 2019 so I had her in
December 2018. so from December 2018 to
December 2019 just before covert all
right I was a stay-at-home mum and I
loved it you know
um everything was covered it it you know
it was the ideal life for me you know I
would make sure that his clothes are
clean I'm ironing his clothes for him
like I'm trying to keep him
as the man like when he comes home from
work he's kind of you know
if I see that he's stressed out I want
to give him some of that some of my
feminine energy because I had a lot to
give at the time
um and try and make his day a little bit
better as much as I could
um but actually how you've done that now
I'm just asking because sometimes men
just want to come and just be left alone
when they're feeling miserable that's it
that's it and women tend to go
try and like jump I mean so I would
gauge that like I'd see like if he
wanted cuddles or you know obviously
I'll see him sitting on the sofa I'd go
and sit on the sofa next to him and if
he wants a cuddle like he that that's
what that's what the leading part of the
men that we don't really talk about so
he'd come over to me and lean over to me
and I know that's my cue you know I'd go
over to him but if he sits still and he
doesn't want me to I know he's had a
really bad time at work and me trying to
cuddle up on him and all that he's just
like men are built differently from us
they don't want that so I I would just
leave him to it you know I'd let him
have his freedom and let him have his
space do do what you got to do
um would you have given that work to
stay at home and be a housewife if my
bills and everything was paid yeah
happily because I really liked it I
really did you know I spent time with my
baby I got to see her first steps I got
to hear her first if I was at work and
like you know in America I think you
guys go back to work a lot sooner than
that I would have missed all of that and
you don't know what's happening with
your child like you said you know you
want your kid to go to Nursery when they
can form sentences I wish I had that
because I was really anxious she was she
was what uh well covered here so she was
still at home with me but I think she
was really two years old when she went
to Nursery so some kids that's old you
know that I know but
for me so
um would you have gone down in lifestyle
in order to attain that
so maybe like move to I don't know a
house or an apartment half the size yeah
yeah yeah because we lived in a really
small place and then when I got pregnant
we moved to a bigger place so if it
meant that I could still stay at home
and you know would you have stayed in a
smaller place yeah yeah yeah okay no
problem at all I mean me talking about
earlier you know having maids and all
that's for me that's a dream you know
and
um that's what my my parents have and
the kind of life that I came from but
it's not the life that I had with him
because I think I was kind of
not only battling with age but also
thinking you know you know Muslim girls
we get married young and how old were
you when you got married 28 wow so
that's you know that's hard for a man no
because I mean like you've been in a
career since you were 16. that's like 12
years of doing what you like and working
your own yeah you know what I mean and
then to come in
wow yeah so that you know the medals
used to there was there was a lot that I
had to
change and I think that's what um this
point in that it's a career woman you
see career woman a career woman right
career woman take notes
what do you what do you do
um I'm an assistant accountant in an
investment bank so yeah okay and you
really like that
um it's really hectic but it's good
money let me just put it that way yeah
you don't even seem to like it that much
it's long hours it's not enjoyable when
you work longer how many how many hours
a week you work uh definitely I think
about
um about maybe 45 hours a week I'd say
that's how long I work isn't that normal
yeah
[Music]
um
yeah 34 is the normal really yeah I
worked in sales before I just thought
everyone worked like 40 to 50 I thought
it was normal oh yeah this is normal
yeah 40 hours is the average and then I
thought he was like I was expecting to
say like 50 55. I mean it could get to
that but I think right now that's the
average that I work with by okay so yeah
how long have you been doing that
um I only got into it quite recently so
I've been there for about two months now
um so it's com it's a completely new
industry that I'm in because where I was
before was like more relaxed where I am
now because it's like really intense
because it's like the banking industry
you already know that that's what to
expect you're going to be working longer
hours so yeah I think I'm just still
getting used to that lifestyle that's
why like everything for me right now is
very fast paced and yeah so I'm still
new to it still easing into that
lifestyle but it's it's a good
experience to have especially I like at
the age that I'm at right now because
I'm 24.
so I think yeah it's it's good for me to
but it's like you might have a
completely different Outlook in five
years exactly you're tired it's been two
months and then you said it's a lot and
it's been two months maybe the
adjustments I mean yeah which is it's
fine yeah yeah I think because I'm new
to everything that's why it's a lot but
I think over a period of time definitely
like kind of take less it kind of
reminds me of my first sales job and it
was like very intense you know and at
first it was like exciting I was like
I'm at this corporate company it's so
fun and then it was like two years later
I hated it I hate it I wanted to leave
so bad
um and God just ask a question to the
married ladies
do you think it would have been easier
for you to both of you if you had not
had your professional life and you'd
settle down earlier 100 yeah 100 I was
just saying it to my sister the other
day um I wish I got married at around 18
19 20. by now my child would have been
teenager you know it it just would have
been a lot easier I'm I've got a you
know a child that's just out of the
toddler phase and I'm knackered because
I find that nowadays what they're saying
the women is like yeah work get your
career yeah
when you can have a child and then when
I come along and say but we won't serve
each other that late yeah I mean like
why would you want to do that why not
encourage the youth to settle down
earlier but now it just seems like
for me it's like all backwards now it's
a lifestyle that I wouldn't have felt
like I was letting go of because I just
grew up and then I got married of which
I wanted to and that is where life began
whereas before it's like I'm living this
one lifestyle and it's about to like
switch to a completely different one so
sometimes like you're living a bit
double not not double-minded by like
your mind is where it was and sometimes
you're trying to merge the two or
sometimes like you're kind of grieving
what it used to be it's you can't really
be present it's just yeah it's just a
lot of
feelings and memories because I mean
I've I've never heard of a Muslim woman
working so many years
you know I mean well done to you because
you studied and you worked in that yeah
yeah but that's unusual for me and the
people that the Muslims that I know
today is really unusual yeah so
um I know a couple yeah
um I've always been headstrong like I'm
the eldest and there's six of us so I've
always wanted to kind of set an example
for my siblings and not only you know
integrate into the Western world but
also
I had this independent woman mindset I
want to make my own money yeah I want to
do my own thing and I wasn't paying
attention to reality and reality for me
and I'm not you know whoever has you
know their opinions that's up to them
but for me reality is a family consists
of a man and a woman and the man is the
head of the family what he's he gets the
last word and me I'm there to nurture
I'm there to mother I'm there to you
know just make everyone feel better and
just do what needs to be done just
understand I need to click with him you
know we both need I need to know that
and trust that he can take care of the
hard stuff
so would you think that it would have
been easier for you and your husband
if you met him when he was like say 17
before you had all the careers no I
would have gotten married to an older
man with the mindset that I've got now
I've gotten married to an older man
who's already established and who is
looking for a younger wife and a lot of
men that's what they want because the
younger you are your fertility like you
can have more kids you know um
and you're more fertile sorry not have
more kids
um so I would have looked for an old man
that would take care of would you marry
a guy that's 55 now
I don't know I don't know it was 50 some
I mean I'm 35 so that's only 20 years
right but
50 year olds nowadays they just I don't
know like we've got two complete
completely different mindsets and I just
don't know older than that yeah yeah
yeah no no no no no no no no no it's
just it's interesting because you said
you would have married older but now
because I'm thinking at 35 like a 45
year old guy can go down to like 25 but
a 55 year old guy like 35 is Young to
him so I'm saying like you know that's
the equivalent now I'm uh so I'm in a
different place in my life now but had I
have been 18 or 19 a 30 something year
old wouldn't have been as a scary right
right okay
yeah can I ask sorry something you said
before I'm just
intrigued about it why do you think the
man should always have the last word
what did you mean if he's if he's a
masculine man who has been brought up
right
and he knows what a woman's right is so
in Islam they teach you about what a
woman's right is how you know what God
is how God expects you to treat that
woman if he understands that
then I trust that whatever decision he's
making is for my best interest and for
our family's best interest not to say
that I don't know what's good for us but
we're emotional creatures sometimes we
think illogically and they don't have
you ever dated a guy that you could
control
you're asking me yeah
that's a big question uh-huh
um
[Laughter]
yeah
um and how did that end
it ended did you like it no I'm saying
no who broke up I didn't I like to be
put in my place I love that yeah
I love it that's her Point yeah okay
you wouldn't even like a guy that wants
you to have the last word no yeah I was
the one that can challenge me and put me
in my place but also appreciate when I
have a good point to convey no you can
sit down and have a conversation
okay that we will talk about it and you
know he will take my opinion into
consideration but at the end of the day
he is making that decision for our
family and I know that and I understand
that very well all right I'm with you
yeah
um okay I'm gonna Read Super chats and
then I think we're going to close out
the show Auntie did you you just seemed
like you wanted to say something no I
was gonna do that oh okay okay I'm gonna
Read Super chats really quick I'm gonna
let you guys do final thoughts so you
can plug any social media or you know
anything you want to say
that is not disrespectful
after last
um also update Esther is banned from the
show anyone was wondering
don't worry about it
um Despicable D um question for the lady
next to Auntie an investment banking
bank and created and destroyed
um Nicholas nasty um women used to earn
safety fund over time in the form of
gold silver and jewelry the gifts used
to have more meaning behind them when
gold and silver with money still does
some in some places in the world Andrew
luster came into the stream late so I
didn't catch names but this lady in the
black leather jacket is based AF bless
you for being a beacon of light on the
podcast
um narcy boy is indiscriminate verbal
Road Ridge a deal breaker no wait wait
answer me is indiscriminate verbal road
rage a deal breaker
it should be a deal breaker for men yeah
for both of us both sixes except auntie
Alex got pissed at me once she was like
WTF those are kids I'm despicable D I
wouldn't get married again but the wife
is I'd want would be respectful brings
peace and intimacy and handles her end
in the day today it's not rocket science
so Auntie when will Pearl see the Dance
Floor
she missed the class today because she
she has a match she had a I had a class
today at that school she said that you
were doing volleyball oh I did have a
game yeah yeah I did um yabba dabba Al
just wanted to say you look beautiful
pearl I love the way you did your hair
I'm a newlywed and watched to learn how
to be a better wife um see Dumbledore
pretend you're married describe your day
me me me me my kids me me me never once
mentioned you about your ATM machine
also known as your husband Dallas loans
can long sleeved black shirt cook is
that why dude got skinny I'm sorry that
was horrible that was just all for the
joke
um
what's the incentive for a hiring man to
be in a relationship with a modern woman
um Carlos acts regarding no corn men
need to unload regularly to keep their
head clear your girlfriend or your wife
isn't always going to be available corn
fills Gap mag oh I already did Maggie
The Substitute Teacher um also I'm gonna
have a couple announcements after they
they go so I'm gonna let you guys do any
final thoughts you guys have
um try to keep it like 30 seconds or
less and then any social media you want
to plug so then go here around and then
second row go ahead
um I enjoyed the conversation that we
had today
um that kind of made me laugh about uh
it's me me and my kids so
um that made me chuckle but um you can
find me at splashofshawn on socials
YouTube Instagram
um yeah
I also really enjoyed the conversations
today I feel like I've learned a lot
about different people and different
walks of life which always opens my mind
to new things uh so definitely been
educated today lovely to meet you all my
socials are Alanya Jaffa and I'm a nail
tech my socials for that is Alanya Nails
underscore
foreign
yeah we go around this way my answer is
yes I can cook when I can be bothered
I'm gonna be honest about it I'm not
always
in the mind frame to do it
um and I did cook for him
and I'm pretty good when I try and um my
socials are Natalie good official check
out my EP that I dropped close to
closure
um I just wanted to say a word for us
all and people that are watching we've
been stay teachable stay humble and I
don't think it's bad to like hear from
traditional wives and women like more
modern women today and then just kind of
work out where you go in the middle but
um try like I think we should all try
not to like create our ideals but like
just look at the world today and then
see what we can piece together from that
and
um yeah my socials are Instagram the
stepmom's Club
um I'm a stepmom coach and I coach
single moms and stepparents and I've
just joined YouTube so follow me at
Priscilla painting on YouTube
um really enjoyed the chat today
[Music]
um
I don't have any socials to plug yeah
I do have social media but I only use it
to lurk but I don't post pictures oh
great but yeah
um yeah same nice to meet everybody
really good engaging conversation today
um my tech talk and Instagram is Lola
Manda and
um yeah that's it for me today
Auntie Jenny has a channel everyone go
subscribe it's in the description anyway
oh yeah um Auntie Jenny on YouTube
yeah and um and Instagram you just hit 5
000 followers oh yeah and then Auntie
Jenny says um
YouTube
um Instagram
and Auntie Jenny UK on Tick Tock that's
his food and Bargains and stuff I
haven't put the bargains up there lately
um but um yeah well done I hope to get
invited to All the Single Ladies
weddings
I need to get a hat but I need to get a
hat but yeah I'm looking forward to it
and let me know how you get on with the
babysitting I haven't forgotten you you
know I haven't forgotten how am I gonna
keep like oh don't worry I have people
I'm for wife school I have people
volunteering their children to me so I
can just pass one on to you yeah yeah
yeah I'll just take it I've had it can I
can I borrow a kid from there on
Instagram
I'll give it back don't worry don't
worry I'll give it back
um okay guys
um one thank you for watching the show
this is the first well I guess we had a
show back but I almost had an aneurysm
that show so
um I really enjoyed the peaceful panel
today thank you Jesus
that was fun
um okay guys we are filming um more wife
School episodes and we also I also have
a project I'm doing on the side where I
am interviewing um high value men
um and I'm gonna do like um a how-to
guide for women that talks about what
the high value men in society want so if
if you are one feel free to message me
on Instagram and I will set up an
interview with you it would be very
helpful for this project
um also same with family court attorneys
I'm also doing a project with that so
that's my talk
um so please message me on Instagram if
you have any experience in the family
court system that would be very helpful
to me like the video on your way out um
a couple announcements um the first is
that we are having our million party in
June go subscribe to my two
um Clips channels Pearl daily and just
Pearl Eclipse also guys if you want to
see me freestyle rap
um sign up for a 10 tier because you can
see that on the 10 tier of our
membership also sign up for our
memberships the highest tier you get a
one-on-one call with me once a month I
really recommend this if you are trying
to grow on YouTube I
honestly can help you avoid a lot of
problems that took me a lot of time that
you guys can avoid so I think that would
be the most helpful out of all of my
membership tiers like the video on your
way out subscribe to the channel thank
you for watching and I will talk to you
next